TODAY'S JOINT HEARING OF SUB
ONE AND SUB FOR ON
HOMELESSNESS- I WANT TO START
BY ACKNOWLEDGING MY CO CHAIR
WHO'S HERE WITH ME TODAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER WHO WILL
FOLLOW WITH SOME OPENING
COMMENTS. BUT SINCE- WE JUST
HEARD A STATE OF THE STATE I
DID WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
GOVERNOR ON HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. IT IS COMPLEX AND
WILL REQUIRE US AS A STATE TO
LEAN IN- I WISH IT WAS AS EASY
AS HE SAID AS A DOCTOR BEING%
ABLE TO WRITE A PRESCRIPTION
FOR HOUSING. AND YET KNOW THAT
OFTEN TIMES THERE'S PUBLIC
PROCESS WHICH IS QUITE
IMPORTANT AND PUBLIC TESTIMONY
AND SO. WE WILL HOLD THIS
HEARING TODAY TO HEAR FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
ABOUT SOME OF THE PROPOSALS-
BUT DO HOPE WE AS A STATE CAN
CONTINUE TO LEAN AND LOOK TO
THIS GOVERNOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE. WITH THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER. THANK YOU. DOCTOR
AMBLE- LOOKING THE JOINT
HEARING ON HOMELESSNESS. TO
THEIR COMMITTEES CONTINUE TO
EXAMINE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ON HOMELESSNESS AS WELL AS
DISCUSS ALTERNATIVES. TO HIS
PLAN. I DO BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
TO PROBLEMS TO ADDRESS WITH
REGARD TO HOMELESSNESS. THAT
INCLUDE HAILING THE KERN
EMERGENCY ON THE STREETS AND
INSURING THAT MORE PEOPLE DAHLE
FALLING HOMELESSNESS. THE
PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS. MILL WORKS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS THAT IS
SIMPLY TO BUILD MORE HOUSING
WHICH INCLUDES. LIMITING RIGHT.
AS A GOVERNOR'S DID TO THE
STATE TODAY. AND PROVIDE
SERVICES. BUT THE GOVERNOR HAS
CALL FOR EARLY ACTION. I WANT
TO MAKE SURE USE OUR TIME.
TODAY EFFECTIVE. LAST WEEK
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE SIX HELD A
HEARING. WHETHER WE DISCUSSED
OUR CONCERNS OF TE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO SPECIFICALLY.
I'M SEES ME THIS THIS. REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE I'M HOPING WE CAN MOVE
BEYOND THAT HEARING AND GET TO
THE HEART OF THE EFFORT BEFORE
US. WHAT PROBLEMS ARE WE TRYING
TO SOLVE IN THIS EARLY ACTION
EFFORT. TODAY I WANT TO FOCUS
ON THE FOLLOWING THEMES
INCLUDED THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL. ONE BEING
REGIONALIZATION. TO
ACCOUNTABILITY THREE NOT SPRING
THE FUNDING TO THIN AND FOR HOW
TAKE. TAKE THE SAME APPROACH
DOESN'T WORK. I DON'T LIKE TO
HEAR FROM OUR PANELISTS ON HELP
POLLS OLD ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
IN SOME RESPECTS ON HEAT ON HOW
HE PARKS AND HAPPY. DID NOT IN
THEIR OPINION. I ALSO LIKE TO
WELCOME ALL MEMBERS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND BY ANY MEMBER
TO MAKE AN OPENING STATEMENT.
WE SOME GREAT PANELS TODAY
SELECT STAR BY INVITING LOTUS
FROM ALICE FROM LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE TO BEGIN. MR
LACKEY YOU HAVE ANY. COMMENTS
WELL. THERE YOU GO I LIKE THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M YOUR BEST
MORALIS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL BE MAKING
COMMENTS AND REFERENCING THE
TENDER BUT I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU. AT THE HEAD CAN
PROVIDING SOME CONTEXT TO THE
STATE OF HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA- THE FIGURE ON PAGE
TWO LAYS OUT SOME
CHARACTERISTIC CLEAN OUT THE
SIZE OF THE HOME WITH THIS
POPULATION AT ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. A STATEWIDE NOTING
THAT CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT 27% OF
THE STATE'S HOMELESS POPULATION
WITH ABOUT 23% OF THIS
POPULATION HAVING A SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS AND 227% OF THE
POPULATION BEING CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS. HE OF THE HAND OUT ON
TO LAY OUT THE STATE AND LOCAL
RELATIONSHIP HISTORICALLY IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS WE SEE
THAT HISTORICALLY NOW I'M
SPEAKING FROM PAGE FOR. THE
STATE HAS PROVIDED A NUMBER OF
SERVICES THAT REALLY RELATE TO
SORT OF FOUR AT THIRTY THREE
MAIN AREAS IN EITHER. HELPING
TO BUILD NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THROUGH THE FORM OF TAX CREDITS
HELPING INDIVIDUALS AFFORD
HOUSING THROUGH THINGS LIKE
VOUCHERS AND THEN PROVIDING
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS THAT WHILE NOT
DIRECTLY RELATED TO. HOUSING
HELP BILLS OF SELF THE STAIN ON
THE TH OF THE STATE AND SEE-
SUFFICIENT EXCUSE ME WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN UP PREVENT
AN ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS- AT THE
DELIVERY OF THE SERVICE THE
STATE WIDE HAVE COME FROM. A
NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS IN A
NUMBER OF FUNDING SOURCES AND
WE'VE SEEN THAT FUNDING HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY FROM YEAR
TO YEAR DUE IN PART TO SOME
RECENT- ONE TIME AUGMENTATION
THAT HAVE BEEN RATHER LARGE. SO
WITH. USE OF THE STATE AND
DOLLARS WE SEE THAT SERVICES
I'VE REALLY BEEN HISTORICALLY
PROVIDED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WITH A UNDERSTANDING THAT
LOCALS ARE MOST IN TUNE TO THE
HOMELESS NEEDS WITHIN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. SO ON PAGE SIX WE
LAY OUT THE THREE MOST
SIGNIFICANT PROGRAMS WE'VE SEEN
IN RECENT YEARS WHERE THE STATE
HAS DEMONSTRATED SIGNIFICANT
ONE TIME DOLLARS IN INTEREST IN
SUPPORTING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS WITHIN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES. THESE
PROGRAMS WHY ARE THERE APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS IS AS IN THE CASE
OF NO PLACE LIKE HOME OR
AUTHORIZED THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS. TAKE A SIMILAR TACT
WHERE FUNDING IS DISTRIBUTED
LOCALLY EACH WITH THEIR OWN
SENT A SET OF ELIGIBLE USES AN
ELIGIBLE RECIPIENTS BUT
GENERALLY IT THESE HAVE BEEN
CONDUITS OF DELIVERING
RESOURCES TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT THEY CAN ADDRESS.
HOMELESSNESS WITHIN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY IN TOTAL WE SEE OVER
THREE BILLION DOLLARS BEING
MADE AVAILABLE THROUGH THESE
THREE SOURCES. IN THE BEGINNING
ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE HAND OUT
WE SEE- TABLE THAT PROVIDES A
HIGH LEVEL DESCRIPTION OF THE
KEY COMPONENTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S- HOMELESSNESS PLAN
BOTH RELATED TO HIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER AS WELL AS COMPONENT THAT
WERE INCLUDED IN HIS BUDGET FOR
THIS. UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR. I
REALLY FOCUS OUR MY SUBSEQUENT
COMMENTS ON THE FIRST TWO ITEMS
UNDER THE BUDGET TO THIS IS THE
CASF FUND THE- AS WELL AS
CHANGES TO MEDICARE I'LL- SO I
KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION
PROVIDING MORE DETAIL ABOUT HOW
THESE PROPOSAL WORK. BUT
GENERALLY WE SEE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- DEPOSITED TOWARDS THIS
NEW SYSTEM WITHIN DFF THAT
ESTABLISHES REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS AND DELIVERS
FUNDS LOCALLY. AS WELL AS-
REFORMS TO MEDIC COW THAT WOULD
MAKE HEALTH RELATED I'M SORRY
HOUSING RELATED SERVICES
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM. SO BIG WITH OUR CAR ON
THESE. ON PAGE ELEVEN OF THE
HANDOUT. FOR THE NEW FUND WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- WE JUST KNOW THAT
THIS IS A NEW MECHANISM FOR
DELIVERING SERVICES LOCALLY
WITH THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
REGIONAL ADMINISTRATORS- WHY
ARE THEY NOTED OR TO BRIEFLY
THERE ALREADY A NUMBER OF
ENTITIES INVOLVED IN DELIVERING
HOUSING HOLD WITH THE SERVICES
SO THIS DOES COMPLICATE THE
STATE LOCAL RELATIONSHIP AND
DELIVERING SERVICES. WE ALSO
NOTE THROUGH A REVIEW OF THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- ASSISTED
WITH THIS PROPOSAL THAT THERE
IS SIGNIFICANT A DELEGATION OF
DECISION MAKING AUTHORITY TO DS
ASKED UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ABOUT HOW THE REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS WOULD BE CHOSEN
AND WHAT SERVICES WOULD BE
PROVIDED LOCALLY. SO ODD BEGIN
ON PAGE ELEVEN WE RAISE A
NUMBER OF KEY QUESTIONS THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER THAT
EVALUATES THE MERITS OF THAT
APPROACH PROPOSAL. A PEACH
TWELVE ADJUSTER TO CLOSE MY
COMMENTS ON THIS- IN THIS AREA
NOTING THAT STRUCK EARLY
OBLIGATION NO WOULD COMMIT THE
LEGISLATURE- TOO FUNNY IN A
PARTICULAR STRATEGY. EARLY ON
IN IN. THE DELIBERATION OF THE
BUDGET. RELATED TO THE MEDIC
HELP. WILL JUST NOTE THAT THIS
IN THIS I'M SPEAKING PAGE. NOW
THIS IS A NOVEL APPROACH FOR
USE THE MEDICAL FUNDING TO
DELIVER TO THE NON MEDI CAL
HOUSING RELATED SERVICES. I
ALSO NOTE THAT. THE GOVERNOR'S
ALSO PROPOSING A NUMBER OF
CHANGES RELATED TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. AND SO- FOR ALL WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IS THAT TO THE GIVEN
THE SCALE OF THE HOMELESSNESS
CHALLENGES THE GOVERNOR'S
EFFORTS TO MAKE CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS IN THIS AREA SEEMS
WARRANTED AN INDIVIDUAL
COMPONENTS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO MERIT
CONSIDERATION. HOWEVER OUR
COMMENTS REALLY FOCUSES OF THE
LACK OF A COHESIVE APPROACH
TAKEN OF ALL OF THE COMPONENTS
TOGETHER AND CONCERNS THAT
THERE MIGHT BE ADDITIONAL
FRAGMENTATION AS A RESULT. AND
SO WE DO THINK THAT THERE IS A
NEED FOR A CLEAR STRATEGY
MOVING FORWARD AS I FOR THE
LATE OUT IN RECENT YEARS. THE
LEGISLATURE THE MACHINE OF
TAKEN A YEAR BY YEAR APPROACH
AND SO NOW IN ITS THIRD YEAR IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE IS A
DEMONSTRATED INTEREST IN
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT. SO WE
THINK THAT SORT OF A LOOK BACK
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A
STRATEGY THAT'S GONNA
COMPREHENSIVE MOVING FORWARD IS
NEEDED. AND SO WE DO RECOMMEND
WITHHOLDING EARLY ACTION TO
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TIME SIR
TO THINK THROUGH THE KEY
DECISIONS AND ON PAGE SIXTEEN
OF YOUR HAND OUT WITH HER. OUT
TO THE AN ISSUE. RIGHT WITHIN.
THROUGH THE LARGEST LONG PLAN
AND I DID A CALL AND MAKE A
SURE THAT SOLUTIONS ARE. WITH
THE AND- FUNDING SOURCE. ARE ON
THE PAGE OF THE- WHICH IS NOT
THAT WE UNDER. THAT THERE IS A
DESIRE. TO MAKE MOVE QUICKLY
AND BRING RELIEF TO THE
INDIVIDUALS- EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS STATEWIDE AND
DEVELOPING A PLAN WILL TAKE
TIME. AND SO IF THERE IS A LEAD
INTERESTED IN MOVING FORWARD
WHILE THE PLAN TAKES SHAPE WE
DO THINK THAT THERE COULD BE- A
ONE TIME A PROPOSAL ALLOCATED
THIS YEAR YOU. SEEN THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION POSTS
THE GOVERNOR OR SOME DIFFERENT
MOUNT. USING MECHANISMS THAT
ALREADY EXISTS TODAY. OF YOUR
GOING. TO NEW MECHANISM AND
YOU'RE SHOULD READY TO CONTINUE
DOWN THAT PATH LONG TERM. YOU
TO TAKE IN YOUR QUESTION THANK.
I AM I MAY START AND THEN
LOOKED OTHER COMMITTEE WHO WON
TO IN. I'M ALSO WITH YOUR CAR
IF I MAY. LOCALS ARE MORE
ATTUNED THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES.
WE'VE INVESTED THREE BILLION
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
HOW OLD WE'VE BEEN DOING. SO
THESE PROGRAMS ARE REALLY IN
THE EARLY SAYS EARLY STAGES AND
SO. WE HAVEN'T REALLY QUITE
SEEN ENOUGH INFORMATION TO
REALLY ASSESS HOW IT'S WORKING-
THEY KEEP FUNDING FOR EXAMPLE-
THAT FUNDING WAS JUST MADE
AVAILABLE THROUGH- IT. JANUARY
OF TWENTY NINETEEN. I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE POINT IN TIME COUNTS AND
SEEN THE 16% INCREASE BETWEEN
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN. ARE THE
KEEP MONEY REALLY WASN'T
AVAILABLE IN TIME TO REALLY
MAKE REFLECTS THAT THAT JUMP IN
HOMELESSNESS UP POPULATION TO
THE STATE WIDE. AND WE DO KNOW
THAT THE FIRST ANNUAL REPORTS
ARE DUE FROM CITIES AND SEE IF
HE'S RELATED TO THEIR HEAT
FUNDING THAT WAS JUST DUE IN
JANUARY AND WE UNDERSTAND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS REVIEWING TO
SEE. HOW THAT'S GOING. ONE OF
THE CENTRAL THEME ALSO SEEMS OF
ACCOUNTABLE. AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION AT THIS TIME. IN HIS
STATE OF THE STATE THE GOVERNOR
LISTED FOR. PRIORITY AREAS FOR
US TO FOLLOW- I TOOK A PICTURE
OF IT SO I COULD TELL YOU WHAT
THEY WERE. NUMBER OF NEW LEASES
SIGNED NUMBER OF NEW HOUSING
UNITS CONVERTED OR BUILT.
NUMBER OF PEOPLE STABILIZE WITH
RENT SUBSIDIES AND NUMBER OF
PEOPLE MOVED OFF THE STREETS.
WOULD YOU. WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
THOSE FOR- AREAS METRICS FOR US
TO EVALUATE DO YOU THINK THERE
ARE ANY OTHERS THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR US TO ADD. AND
HOW REALISTIC IS IT FOR
COUNTIES ARE REGION'S TO REPORT
THIS TYPE OF DATA IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY. SO FOR AT ANY
PROGRAM WHERE STATE RESOURCES
ARE BEING GIVEN TO LOCALS
HAVING ROBUST MECHANISM FOR
OVERSIGHT IS IMPORTANT BOTH
MEASURES THAT TRACK PROGRESS
BUT THEN ALSO HOLD. INDIVIDUALS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR OUT CONS. SO
AND WE THINK THAT ANY
STRUCTURES ARE MOVING FORWARD
SHOULD HAVE THOSE MEASURES IN
PLACE- THE MEASURE DELAYED OUT
TO SOUND REASONABLE AND WE JUST
THINK ANY SORT OF ROBUST-
PROCESS. SHOULD BE A PART OF
YOU KNOW ONGOING INVESTMENTS
WILL IF THERE ARE ANY OTHERS
THAT YOU ARE THE LA- THINK OF
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT FEEDBACK
SO WE CAN FOLLOW UP AND- SEE IF
THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN ADD. I
WOULD ECHO WANTING THIS
INFORMATION SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER TO ACTUALLY FLUSH OUT THE
PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT I. YOU KNOW
HAVE TO PUT MY BIASES OUT THERE
AS WELL I SEE HOUSING HAS
HEALTH. IT'S REALLY HARD TO
KEEP PEOPLE HEALTHY IF THEY'RE
LIVING ON THE STREETS. AND SO I
THINK THERE IS LOGIC TO. BRING
IN THIS INTO DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND- APPLAUDED
THE GOVERNOR FOR WANTING TO.
TAKE ON THIS CRITICAL OF AN
ISSUE. OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
TALKING ABOUT IT AND IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS PUBLIC
SERVANTS TO WORK ON IT AND SO-
I'VE JUST ENCOURAGE THIS BODY
TO CONTINUE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE BEING
EFFECTIVE WITH THOSE DOLLARS AS
WELL SO. WITH THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER THANK YOU
CELESTIAL SPENT SIX THIRTY
MILLION ON HALF AND THAT MONEY
STILL NOT BEEN RELEASED SO IT'S
KIND OF HARD TO HAVE A METRIC.
IF THE MONEY IS STILL SITTING
THERE HAVE BEEN SPENT I AND WE
TALK ABOUT BUILDING IN. TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
MULTI FAMILY BUILDING WAS DOWN
11% SO YOU KNOW I GOVERNOR'S
WAS GREAT I HER A LOT. BUT YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES IS
YOU CAN'T SPEND YOUR WAY OUT OF
THIS. IT TOOK A LONG TIME FOR
US TO GET HERE AND WE'RE NOT
IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN OVERNIGHT
I MEAN PEOPLE ARE BUILDING.
THINK ABOUT THE NUMBER STATE
BUILDINGS DOWNTOWN. A LOT OF
WORKERS ARE DOWN HERE SO
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS FOR
HOUSING. INCOME HOUSING YOU
WANT IS A STORAGE LOCAL SCHOOL
THE BAY AREA BECAUSE IT'S
ALWAYS A HIGHER THERE THE
COMMITTEE FROM SACRAMENTO SO
TO. THINK THAT WE'RE GONNA ALSO
AND JUST PUSH A BUTTON. AND GO
FROM THE GROUND UP THAT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPEN. SO IT'S A
DELIBERATE EFFORT AND HOW WE DO
IT- AND ALSO I KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT THE SEQUEL SOMETIMES A
LOT OF FOLKS DON'T WANNA TALK
ABOUT IT BUT- THERE'S A PROJECT
HERE DOWNTOWN IT WAS BUILT IN
NINETEEN STORY. IT WAS MIXED
USE CELL FOR WILL HOUSING IT
GOT SUED. AND WITH SOMEONE SUES
FOR SPEAK WITH DOCTOR FIVE
YEARS FOR THE TYPICAL LAWSUIT.
THAT YOU CAN BUILD AND CLIFF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IMPAIR. MR
ALMOST COULD TALK ABOUT IT TOO-
THIS IS ALL THE TIME. YEAH YOU
CAN BUILD A BRAND NEW ARENA
DOWNTOWN. YOU CAN CONTINUE. ON
ITS COURSE. AND DRESS ISSUES
THAT HAVE MERIT. BUT YOU CAN'T
FOR HOW. AND WE SEE THAT TIME
TIME AGAIN FOR BLOUSE MULTI
FAMILY HOW. PEOPLE SUING THAT
DON'T REALLY HAVE A VESTED
INTEREST. OF THEM BEING NIMBY
THAT DON'T WANT IT YOU KNOW IN
THEIR BACKYARD. IN AND HOW DO
WE CHANGE THAT. SO LOOK. I
WOULD ASK THE LA- IS- WHAT
SHOULD BE THE STATE'S ROLE IN
HOMELESSNESS. THAT'S A
DIFFICULT QUESTION- THAT'S ONE
OF THE YOU KNOW KEY I THINK
THAT WE SORT OF SUGGESTED
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THE
DEVELOP A STRATEGY MOVING
FORWARD. WE HAVE SEEN THAT
HISTORICALLY THE STATE'S ROLE
HAS BEEN IN. PROVIDING
RESOURCES TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO HELP THEM- YOU KNOW INVEST
THAT MONEY LOCALLY AS THEY SEE
FIT- THAT'S ONE OF THE
DECISIONS YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE COULD TAKE A NEW
APPROACH ON MOVING FORWARD IF
IT WANTS TO TAKE. A LARGER ROLE
IN MOVING BEYOND JUST PROVIDING
FUNDING PERHAPS DEVELOPING. YOU
KNOW POLICY DECISIONS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THAT WOULD BE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WOULD
AFFECT. NOT ONLY TO THAT THE
FUNDING BETTER WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE MOVING FORWARD. A LOCAL.
HOW DOES THE GOVERNOR'S.
ADDRESS REGIONALS. ACCOUNT AND
NOT SPREADING MONEY TO SAN. AND
RESPONDING TO THE STATEMENT
THAT THE SAME APPROACH DOESN'T
WORK. HOW DOES THAT DIFFER FROM
THE FRAMEWORK IN HEAT AND HAPPY
SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IT
DOES ESTABLISH THESE REGIONAL
ENTITIES ORIGINAL
ADMINISTRATORS- AS ABSURD
MENTIONED THE TRAILER BILL- TO
THE PROBABILITY TELL ABOUT HOW
THEY WOULD WORK AND SO THAT'S
ONE OF OUR QUESTIONS OF HOW IT
IF THE- OBJECTIVE IS TO WORK IN
A MORE REGIONAL APPROACH HOW
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
AND- WORK TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
OKAY I JUST WANNA GO BACK TO
THE POINT THAT WITH A LOT OF
MONEY HAS NOT BEEN SPENT
PROBABLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT OTHER
THINGS. A BILLION DOLLARS FROM
LAST YEAR CLOSE RESOLVED ALMOST
A BILLION DOLLARS ISSUE YOU CAN
BUY EVERYTHING TOGETHER SO. IT
HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A LONG
TIME GETTING A DRESSED LIKE I
SAID. THIS IS BUILT UP- ALSO NO
ONE TALKS ABOUT WHICH WE KEEP
FOCUS ON HOUSING IN. AND
HOUSING IS IMPORTANT PART BUT-
IN THE MIDDLE THIS IS A
CRITICAL PART. THERE'S NOT A
LOT ON THAT. AND I'LL SOME
PANEL TALK ABOUT LATER ON. IN
REALLY ALSO SUBSTANCE ABUSE YOU
KNOW IT'S- IT'S HARD TO GET OFF
OF DRUGS AND EVEN ALCOHOL.
PEOPLE HAVE A HARD TIME WE
RELEASE TOUR IN ARLINGTON. I
KNOW YOU MENTIONED MISSION 27%
FOR MENTAL ILLNESS. I WOULD SAY
THAT'S NUMBERS ARE MUCH MORE.
HIGHER THAN THAT. YOU KNOW IN
DEALING WITH THAT AND- YOU LOOK
AT SACRAMENTO. AND WELL LA IS
DONE THEY PUT A LOT OF MONEY
TOWARDS IT THEMSELVES. AS WE
SEEN REPORTS. THE RETURN WAS A
VERY GOOD WITH THAT. SO LOT OF
COMPLEX THINGS LITTLE BALLS IN
THE AIR WITH THIS- AND
GOVERNOR'S COMMITTED- TO
RESOLVING THIS ISSUE BUT-
THERE'S A LOT TO ADDRESS. IN A
IS NOT GONNA BE THAT EASY LIKE
I SAID. THE JUST FOCUS ON
HOUSING HOUSING HOUSING IS
GOING TO. FIX A PART OF IT BUT
NOT THE OVERALL CIRCUMSTANCES.
I'M GONNA. PIGGY BACK ON THAT-
NO MR APPS RIGHT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS. THE TREATMENT SIDE AND
WE KNOW THE FACTS THE GOVERNOR
MENTION YOU KNOW REALLY IN A
PROP SIXTY THREE AND HOW TO
ADDRESS THAT AND OBVIOUSLY WILL
GET AN ADULT MORE. BY YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU TALK TO SHARES
DEPARTMENTS AND WE FIND OUT
NUMBERS LIKE 63% OF OUR COUNTY
JAILS ARE HOUSING. MENTAL
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PATIENCE BECAUSE THERE'S
NOWHERE ELSE FOR THEM TO GO BUT
YET NOBODY WANTS TO TALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW INSTITUTIONALIZING
FOLKS- YOU KNOW ONE FLEW OVER
THE CUCKOO'S NEST OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT. BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS. YOU KNOW WITHOUT ADDRESS
SEEN PROP 47-57 TAKING THE
TEETH OUT OF PROGRAMS LIKE DRUG
COURT IN THESE THINGS. WHERE
IT'S YOU KNOW IT IT'S NOT
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY ANY LONGER SO
PEOPLE ARE OUT DOING DRUGS ON
THE STREETS. IT'S AN AND NOW
THEY'RE NOT BEING FORCED TO GET
CLEANED UP. A IN THE GOVERNOR
MENTIONED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
LOOKING AT HOW TO. PUT SOME OF
THAT ENFORCEMENT PIECE BACK ON.
BUT HE DIDN'T GO INTO DETAILS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
THE LACK OF DETAILS ON THE LACK
OF THE MECHANICS THAT WE'VE GOT
A WERE BOTH LEGISLATIVELY AND
WITH THE DIFFERENT APARTMENTS
TO FIGURE OUT OKAY. HOW
MECHANICALLY WE PUT THIS
TOGETHER HOW TO WE SAY UP THE
BEST TREATMENT. BECAUSE WE
DON'T NEED PEOPLE SITTING IN
JAIL RODDY IN. WHEN THEY NEED
TREATMENT AND WE ALSO KNOW
THROUGH HISTORY THAT YOU KNOW
DOING THE COMMUNITY BASED OKAY
YEAH YOU CAN TELL SOMEBODY THEY
HAVE TO GO IT TREATMENT BUT IF
THEY HAVE A DRUG PROBLEM WHO
SAYS ARE GONNA COME BACK WAS
THE ENFORCEMENT ON THAT. SHOW
REALLY GOT TO BE CAREFUL HOW WE
LOOK AT THESE THINGS MOVING
FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT E GET
ALL THE PIECES CORRECT ON THIS.
AND AGAIN I MEAN THE. THE
SUMMER COOPER KIND OF BEAT ME
TO THE PUNCH ON AS IT. AND TELL
FOLKS GET THE TREATMENT THAT'S
NECESSARY AND GET THEM
TRANSITION BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITIES AND BACK INTO
SOCIETY IN BACK WHERE THEY
COULD BE WORKING. YOU CAN'T
JUST FROM A HOUSE. IN SOME OF
THE STREAMING OPTIONS ARE GONNA
TAKE NO YEARS FOR SOME OF THESE
FOLKS SO WE REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON ADDRESSING THAT
TREATMENT SIDE AND YOU KNOW
IT'S GOING TO TAKE YEARS
DEVELOP THESE HOUSES PLUS THE
WORK FORCE PLUS EVERYTHING
ELSE. PLUS THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE A SHORTAGE ON MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN THE
STATE AND EVERYTHING ELSE SO
IT'S- YOU THERE'S NOT A BUTTON
ARE SWITCH JUST THE PORTION
IT'S MAGICALLY KANAB HERE YOU
HAVE TO BUILD AND ALL THE
PIECES TO GET US UP TO THAT.
THAT WE'VE LOST OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF DECADES SO I KNOW
THAT'S A LOT ALL AT ONCE. BUT I
MEAN. WE HAVE TO FIGURE THIS
OUT AND MAKE SURE THE MECHANICS
ARE GONNA WORK. WERE EVERYTHING
FALLS THROUGH THE CRACKS YET
AGAIN. A INTERN NOT GONNA SPEND
YOUR WAY OUT OF THIS SO I MEAN
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AS WE LOOK
IT. THE PROPOSALS I THINK WE'RE
REALLY GONNA NEED. AS
LEGISLATIVE BODY HELP MAKING
SURE THOSE MECHANICAL PIECES
FIT TOGETHER RIGHT. SO THESE
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY WORK- BECAUSE
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE A PROGRAM.
BUT IF IT THE MECHANICS DON'T
WORK IT'S USELESS. AND AS WE'VE
SEEN BEFORE. AS MENTIONED
EARLIER WE CAN HAVE A PROGRAM
BUT IF THERE'S NO FUNDING AND
IT IS JUST AN AT THE SHELL SO
IT'S A GREAT HEADLINE BUT IT
DOES NOTHING. SO WE'VE GOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. YOU KNOW IS NOT
AN EMPTY SHELVES AND THE PIECES
OFF IT NETWORKS SHALL. I LOOK
FORWARD TO. PUTTING ALL OF THAT
TOGETHER OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS. SPEAKING OF PUTTING
PIECES TOGETHER WE HAVE A
QUORUM OF SUB ONE AND SO I JUST
WANT TO TAKE ROLE FOR THAT IF I
CAN. DR AMBULANCE PRESENT
FRAZIER. MATHIS HATTERS. RAMOS
RUBIO DOCTOR WOULD. I WOULD
JUST ASK IF THERE ANY OTHER WE
HAVE FOR LA- ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
AND THEN. SO FOR SOMEONE THANK
YOUR ANALYSIS I KNOW YOU'VE
COME OUT WITH THE NUMBER OF
RECENT. AND PRE. APPRECIATE
THAT- IN THE MOST RECENT REPORT
THAT CAME OUT ON FEB ELEVENTH-
BY ONE OF YOUR TOP LEVEL-
CONCLUSIONS WAS THAT THE PLAN
RUN HOMELESSNESS LACKS COHESION
IS FRAGMENTED EXCEPT FOR A AND-
PART OF THE REASON WHY I KNOW
THE CHAIRS OF THESE COMMITTEES
PUT THIS TOGETHER IS. HOUSING
IS HEALTH HEALTH IS HOUSING-
BUT AS WAS JUST MENTIONED BY
SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN
HOMELESSNESS AND THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM- THE DISABILITIES SAFETY
NET. THE EDUCATION SYSTEM
EXCEPT FOR ALL SILOS THAT WE
WANT TO FIGURE OUT A BREAKDOWN.
OF THE ONE ASK YOU WHETHER YOU
THINK THERE ARE WAYS FOR US TO
AND SENT DIFFERENT POLICY
COMMUNITIES AND DIFFERENT
BUREAUCRACIES WITHIN GOVERNMENT
TO DO BETTER WORK TOGETHER TO
FOCUS ON. THE PLIGHT OF FOLKS
WHO ARE HOMELESS BUT ALSO ARE
INTERACTING WITH DIFFERENT
POLICY SALAS ARE THERE IT
OBVIOUSLY YOUR SUGGESTION IS
RIGHT NOW WE'RE FRAGMENTED
RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT COHESIVE.
IS THERE A BETTER WAY FOR US TO
AFTER THAT AND I WOULD JUST SAY
FOR OTHER PANELS THAT ARE
COMING TO SPEAK IF ANYONE HAS
IDEAS ON THIS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I THINK THERE ARE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN SYSTEM
THAT. ARE HELPING. THE END OF
WE WANT TO HELP BUT BE THEY'RE
TO. WE'RE NOT DOING JOB I'M-
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE PAY IS TO
MOVE THIS FOR SO LOVE IF YOU
ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT. YES SIR.
ARE AS HUMAN REPORT OUT THAT
THERE A LOT OF FACT. THERE A
NEED FOR A THREE PLAN FOR. WE
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU'LL NEED TO GRAPPLE
WITH AS YOU SORT OF THINK
THROUGH AND DEVELOP THAT PLAN
WE DON'T HAVE A READY MADE
ANSWERS FOR YOU TODAY ON A
CREDIT HOW TO DO THAT- IT'S
THOSE ARE TOUGH TRADE OFF THE
DECIDING WHICH POPULATIONS TO
PRIORITIZE IF YOUR- IF YOU'RE
SORT OF TRYING TO FOCUS DOLLARS
MORE A- MORNING. WE ARE WORKING
TO THE CROSS CUTTING ANSWER TO
WHAT THE TRADEOFFS OF SPREADING
DOLLARS MORE THINLY MIGHT BE-
THINK. HEARINGS HAVE BEEN HELD
UP YOUR HELP LAST WEEK. TODAY
IS OUR TO WEEKS IN THE DAYS TO
COME- ARE A GOOD YOU KNOW FOR
STAFF GATHERING. ABOUT WHAT THE
STATE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT ARE
DOING TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE. OF
IT TAKE A TOUGH TO IN THE ONE
OF THE FIRST DECISIONS THE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT THE STATE
ROLE BE LAW TERM. WILL IT
CONTINUE TO BE AS. UNDER FOR
DELIVERY A RESOURCE TO LOCAL
LAW WHAT TAKE MORE UP. IT
ROLLED FULL THAT INFORM. THE
NEW. OF THE PRO. AND MUCH AND-
YOU MIGHT WANT SEE IN THE
FUTURE. FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALMOST. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOLLOWING UP ON THE
LOWER ASK OF IT CERTAINLY HEARD
THE GOVERNOR A STATED THE STATE
TO AND TALKED ABOUT HOMELESS
MENTAL HEALTH BUT ALL TALK
ABOUT IN THAT LOCAL LEVEL WERE-
WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT THERE BUT
YET WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH IN THOSE ARE OUT ON THE
STREET. AND NOW WHERE DO WE PUT
THEM AT WRITING SO I KEEP
TALKING ABOUT CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS AS A PLACE
TO. HAVE AN OPTION FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS WHEN THEY RESPOND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
FIREFIGHTERS. WHEN THEY GOAL
RATHER THAN HAVING TO GO TO
COUNTY JIL OR TO THE EMERGENCY
ROOM FOR A SEVENTY TWO HOUR
HOLD. THAT THEY WOULD HAVE AN
OP TO HIM TO STABILIZATION
UNITS HOWEVER CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS ARE LIMITED
IN THE TIME OF DAY THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY SPEND THERE I THINK
IT'S TWELVE DAYS. NOT SURE WHAT
WE NEED IS LONGER LONG TERM
CRISIS RESIDENCY TREATMENTS SO
WHEN WE START TO MOVE DOWN THIS
ROAD OF HOMELESSNESS AND
PARTICULARLY HOT MENTAL HEALTH
HOMELESSNESS OUT. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF LONG TERM RESIDENCY
TREATMENT NEEDS TO BE ONE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. BUT
BECAUSE NOT WHEN FIRST WRIST TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THESE
EPISODES THE ONLY OPTION
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE IN LESS THAN
INFRASTRUCTURE IS THERE IS
STILL A COUNTY JAILS OR THE
EMERGENCY ROOM BACKING UP. AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL RIGHT IN THE
IMPACT ON THE LOCAL LEVEL
THAT'S THERE SO WE TALK ABOUT
BRINGING SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS
TOGETHER AND I HEAR YOU TALKING
ABOUT LONG TERM SOLUTIONS. NOT
TO BE SO HASTY AND JUMPING
FORWARD BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE LAYING THE
GROUND BREAKING IN THE
DISCUSSION FOR SOME OF THESE
LONG TERM APPROACH THAT WOULD
BUILD SOME OF THESE CRISIS
DOESN'T TREATMENTS THERE'S-
LOCAL. AREAS THAT. TO THAT THAT.
OF NIMBY IS A AND NOT AND BACK
THIS AND THAT WELL WE KNOW THAT
IT'S ENOUGH PUNISHED FOR PROP
EVERY STE. I'M IN THE STATE
HELLO I'M NOT FIFTY COUNTY. BUT
YOU. TACKLE THAT ISSUE THAT'S
NOT BE DISCUSS OF A YOU HAVE
THE RESOURCE TO PUT UP Mà.
WHOSE BE THE FIRST OR FOR
CITIES A BUILD IT IN OUR
BACKYARD THAT'S ONE OF ISSUES
WE HAVE TO. WE ARE AND IN A
HOME VETS AREA DOWN IN IN
DECEMBER DINO AND ONE OF THE
CITIES AND CEREMONIAL COUNTY.
AND IT WAS EIGHTY UNITS FOR
HOMELESS VETERANS BUT YET WHEN
WE HAD TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS RATED BOTH FOR IT. THE
IN THE MIDEAST UP AND SAID.
MAYBE CALL FOR A BETTER FOR IT.
WE ENDED UP LOSING THE FUNDING
FOR THAT WHOLE DEVELOPMENT. SO
WHEN THE GOVERNOR TALKS ABOUT
LOOKING AT THE SURPLUS LAND IN
THE STATE. THAT COULD BE THE
SOLUTION TO THE REGIONAL
APPROACH THAT TAKES AWAY THAT
ARGUMENT BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE TO
START TO DO PEOPLE. WITH THE
HOME IS METAL THAT'S OUT THERE
THE HOMELESS THAT ARE OUT
THERE. IN TO MAKE SURE BRING
SOME TYPE OF SOLUTION TOGETHER
SO I WOULD JUST BRING IT UP
FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL COMING
FROM THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. IF WE DON'T HAVE
THAT STRUCTURE THERE. THE FIRST
PLACE THE PEOPLE END UP LOOKING
AT IS COUNTY JAILS EMERGENCY
ROOMS AGAIN. SO THIS ONE FOR
THE MOST CHAIR. I'M LOOKING FOR
ANY FUND QUESTIONS WE MAY HAVE
BUT- ONE TO MENTION SOMETHING
ELSE CAME UP THE STATE OF THE
STATE. THERE WAS DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT PRUDENT RESERVES WITHIN
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
PRIOR BUDGET AX HAVE CAP THAT
AT THIRTY THREE PERCENT. I
THINK MY QUESTION FOR THE LA-
NOT TO ANSWER NOW. WHAT WOULD
BE AN APPROPRIATE PERCENT SINCE
FORTY OUT OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES ARE CURRENTLY. OVER
THIS 33% RESERVE. HOW COULD HE
INSURE THAT THAT MONEY IS
GETTING SPENT ON PROJECTS THAT
MATTER AND CAN HELP IN
COMMUNITIES NOW AND TODAY SO
WITH THAT I'LL LOOK TO CHAIRED
TING OR ANY OF THE OTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OTHERWISE
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PANEL
ONE ONE THANK LA FOR
PRESENTING. GIVE. THE SO IF WE
COULD HAVE JENNER TRY. G. C.
COOPER AND STAY. QUINN DAN. AND
IN. CAN AFTERNOON SHARES MY
JENNIFER TRY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL. I'M SO AS
WE'VE BEEN JUST THE CRY THAT WE
ALL FACE WITH RISK TO THE IF.
IN CALIFORNIA AND HOMELESSNESS
WE'VE TALKED QUITE A BIT ABOUT%
THE INVESTMENTS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
HAVE MADE IN RECENT YEARS AND-
AND ALSO AS YOU HEARD IN THE
STATE OF THE STATE- THE
GOVERNOR'S VERY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO BUILD UPON THOSE
INVESTMENTS SO WHEN IT BRIEFLY
HIGHLIGHT- THEIR RECENT ACTIONS
THAT HE TOOK ON JANUARY EIGHTH
WITH THE EXECUTIVE ORDER- AND
THEN ALSO TALK. TODAY ABOUT HIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT CAME OUT
ON JANUARY TENTH SO I'M JOINED
BY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND STATE HOSPITALS SO
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS- A NUMBER
OF THESE INVESTMENTS ACROSS THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OPERATED
WITHIN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. THESE
PROPOSALS ARE INTENDED TO BE
CRITICAL PARTS OF A
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE
RESPONSE. IN ALL THESE EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS THE
INTENT IS FOR THE STATE TO LEAD
TO HEAR YOU ASKING ABOUT THE
STATE'S ROLE AND I THINK THE
WAY WE ENVISION THAT THE INTENT
IS FOR THE STATE TO LEAD WITH
RESOURCES AND WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AND THEN TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY WHILE STILL
HONORING THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND LOCAL PARTNERS HAVE A
CRITICAL ROLE IN THE SOLUTIONS
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES. I WILL
FOCUS THE MOST ON THE ACCESS TO
HOUSING AND SERVICES FUND WHICH
IS A PROPOSED TO BE OPERATED
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. THE BUDGET
PROPOSES TO INVEST SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN THAT
NEW FUND- BUT THE INTENTION
HERE IS ALSO FOR THE FINE TO
ACCEPT RESOURCES FROM. FEDERAL
LOCAL PRIVATE CONTRIBUTIONS SO
THAT WE CAN COMBINE AND BLENDS
THOSE RESOURCES AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. THIS MODEL OF
BLENDING IN LEVERAGING FUNDS
SOURCES TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
IS ALREADY IN USE IN SEVERAL
JURISDICTIONS AND SO WE ARE
TRYING TO BUILD. UPON THEIR
SUCCESS AT THE STATE LEVEL. THE
RESOURCES IN THE FOR ARE
INTENDED TO BE USED TO DEVELOP
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
TO PROVIDE SUBSIDIES THAT PAY
RENTS AND PROVIDE TENDENCY
SUPPORT SERVICES AND TO HELP
STABILIZE IN PARTICULAR
BOARDING CARE HOMES. THE INTENT
IS ALSO FOR THE HOUSING
SUPPORTED THROUGH THE FINE TO
BE INTEGRATED WITH SERVICES SO
THAT WE IMPROVE OUTCOMES AND
HAVE LONG TERM ABILITY FOR
PEOPLE TO STAY OUT WEST. THE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES SERVED
ARE ALL. INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
EITHER HOMELESS OR AT IMMINENT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS AND ALL OF
THE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS WILL
BE PROVIDED UNDER HOUSING FIRST
PRINCIPLES. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AS YOU ALREADY HEARD-
ALSO CREATES A NEW STRUCTURE AT
THE REGIONAL LEVEL- THE FUNDING
IS ACTUALLY PROPOSED TO COME
FROM THE DEPARTMENT TO REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS WE WILL REQUIRE
THOSE REGIONAL ADMINISTRATORS
AND THIS IS INCLUDED IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WE HAVE
PROPOSED. TO HAVE X. PARTNER.
WILL ALSO BE SUBJECT TO A CAP
ON ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ALSO SPECIFIES THAT ALLOCATIONS
IN THE REGION'S AMONG THE
REGIONS- WILL BE DETERMINED
BASED ON POINT IN TIME
HOMELESSNESS COUNTS ALONG WITH
MEASURES OF RENT BURDEN. AND
HOUSING NEED AND AN ADDITIONAL
EMPHASIS ON RACIAL EQUITY AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY. THE FUNDS
FOR EACH REGION WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH PERFORMANCE
BASED CONTRACTS WITH SPECIFIC
AND QUANTIFIABLE MEASURES OF
SUCCESS AS THE GOVERNOR
REFERENCE EARLIER TODAY AND THE
CHAIR- REPEATED- BUT WE ARE
WORKING TO- DILIGENTLY DEVELOP
ADDITIONAL DETAILS REGARDING
THOSE PERFORMANCE METRICS BOTH
THE ONES THAT WERE LAID OUT AND
ADDITIONAL ONES. WE BELIEVE
IT'S CRITICAL TO BE INNOVATIVE
AS WE CONFRONT HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA THE REGIONAL
APPROACH IS INTENDED TO
INCENTIVIZE COLLABORATION TO
BRING ECONOMIES OF SCALE AND TO
ALLOW US TO STREAMLINED OUR
PROCESSES WHILE STILL ALLOWING
FOR LOCAL. STATIONS IF NEED.
SEE THAT'S US AS THE AS WELL
POSITIONED TO ADMINISTER THIS
EFFORT WE OPERATE MANY OF THE
STATE SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AND
WE ALSO OPERATE SEVERAL
EXISTING TARGETED HOUSING
SUPPORT AND CLIENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS. SO WE. SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THAT MANY OF YOU HAVE
ALREADY REFERENCED TODAY. WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH STATE AND
LOCAL PARTNERS AND WITH ALL OF
YOU THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS TO
PROVIDE THE ADDITIONAL DETAILS
THAT YOU ARE LOOKING FOR WITH
RESPECT TO THIS EFFORT- SO WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS RIGHT ON IF YOU
PREFER FOR US ALL TO GO HEAD
FIRST. I THINK IF WE HEAR FROM
THE PANEL ONE LAST QUESTION
GREAT AND THAT'S RIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON Y NAME'S JC COOPER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES I AM I AM THE
STATE MEDICAID DIRECTOR- AT THE
DEPARTMENT. SO TODAY WILL FOCUS
MY COMMENTS IN REGARDS TO THE
MEDI CAL COMPONENTS THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET.
ON THERE ARE NUMBER OF PIECES
SO IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
THE DEPARTMENT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH.
COUNTIES MANAGED CARE PLANS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
PROVIDERS TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
THEY'RE OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN
MEDI CAL THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
BEST PRACTICES. WE HEARD A LOT
FROM THAT WE CAME BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN WITH THE
PROPOSAL CALLED MEDI CAL HELP
YOUR CALIFORNIA FOR. AND HIS
CATTLE A- I'M BOB THROUGH. THE
COMPLY WITH IN CASH. IN BACK
I'M- THE TO THE- TODAY OF HOT
NEST. ON THE- TWENTY TWO PURPLE.
I'M IN CALAIS IN I WILL FILL ON
THE ONE FOR THIS ITEM. SO ONE
OF THE PIECES OF THE DEPARTMENT
IS PROPOSING IS A STATE.
BENEFIT CALLED CAN'T SCARE ME.
AS THIS A FIT WAY. I'M AS HOW
TOUCH IT HE YOUR MEN. SIMILAR
TO CA. CASE THE INTENT IS TO.
OUT FOR. COMMUNITY VOTE POP
THEY SHOULDN'T. CLUE THE FOR
HOME. OF HOPE THIS. BOTH THEIR
MEDICAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE GETTING WHAT THEY NEED.
IT'S SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU SEE IN
OUR WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOTS
STATEWIDE. AND OUR HELP COMES
PROGRAM WE ARE PROPOSING TO
TRANSITION THOSE TWO PROGRAMS
INTO NOW IS STATEWIDE MANDATORY
BENEFIT. THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
ACROSS THE STATE TO PROVIDE.
I'M ST BASED SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE HOMELESS POPULATION.
YOU ALSO WILL SEE- EIGHTY-
PROPOSAL FOR IN LIEU OF
SERVICES OF SORRY JUST TO
MENTION- THERE IS A COMMITMENT
OF AN ON GOING FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT
ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT-
BENEFIT IN THE BUDGET. FOR THE
IN LIEU OF SERVICES- AN ANNUAL
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN LIEU OF SERVICES IS
NOT A GREAT NAME- FOR THAT
PARTICULAR SERVICE. I'M IT IS
IT TWO OF THE MORE EXPENSIVE AN
INPATIENT STAY IN EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS. AN E. R. AND WE
HAVE A HOUSING SWEET OR BUNDLE
OF SERVICES THAT WE HAVE
PROPOSED TO ROLL OUT. THROUGH
MEDI CAL IT INCLUDES ON HOUSING
NAVIGATION SERVICES- WHICH
WOULD ALLOW TO WORK WITHOUT TO
FIND HOUSING MAKE THAT THERE
CAN. FOR HOW. I'M TO WORK WITH
ENHANCE THE MANAGE. OF
PROVIDERS TO CONNECT THEM TO
HOUSING INCLUDING WORKING WITH
THE HOUSING FUND IN. TWO I AYE.
CITY HOW CAN PAY FOR RENT SUB.
ITSELF I'M BERMAN SING BUT WE
CAN'T PAY FOR SOME TEMPORARY
HOW. AND ALL OBLIGATION TYPE
SERVICES WHICH ARE ALLOWED. I'M
RIGHT. ALSO WITH. IT WOULD ALSO
COME LIAISON TYPES. HAVE
SOMEONE IS HOUSE WORKING WITH
THEM TO STAY HOUSE WORKING WITH
WHETHER THAT'S THE LANDLORD OR
OTHER PEOPLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN SAFELY RESIDE IN THE
HOME AND THAT THERE
SUCCESSFULLY HOUSE. I'M REMAIN
PERMANENTLY HOUSE AFTER THAT.
THERE ARE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES-
AROUND RETRIBUTIVE KERR SO
SOMEONE A HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS AN INPATIENT SETTING OR
IN AN INSTITUTIONAL SETTING OR
EVEN IN A ARE SERRATED SET
TRANSIT THING OUT. BEING ABLE
TO GO TO RECRUIT PREDICT SAID
PROVIDE. SOME COOL SERVICES
THAT THEY HAVE HIGH MEDICAL OR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS. TO
TRANSITION TO THE STUDY. AND WE
ALSO HAVE A DATE ABILITY XIN
PROGRAM FOR HOME ASSIST. IN
URBAN AREAS. YOU CAN. SET AS
CASE. THAT'LL FIRST SIR OUR
HOME WHICH WILL COME TO. THAT
ENOUGH TO HELP. I'M CAN I THEM
TO MISTER. OTHER. ALL PROPOSAL-
AND I WILL GO OVER THEM
QUICKLY- WE ALSO ARE PROPOSING
PAYMENT REFORM FOR BOTH MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES WE CURRENTLY
PAY OUR COUNTIES IN A COST.
BASED REIMBURSEMENT MECHANISM
ON WHICH TO LIMIT THEIR ABILITY
ON TO IT INCREASE REVENUE AND
POTENTIALLY REINVEST THOSE
DOLLARS AN INCREASE ACT AS A
MENTAL HEALTH AND A- SERVICES-
SO WE ARE PROPOSED. ARM FOR
THOSE TWO EIGHT. WE ARE ARE
LOOKING AT WHAT WE CALL MEDICAL
NECESSITY WHEN IT COMES TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA
SPECIFICALLY TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO GET ADEQUATE
ACCESS TO THOSE SERVICES. AND
REMOVING UNINTENDED BARRIERS
THAT PUT IN PLACE OVER MANY
YEARS I'M TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
CAN GET THE TREATMENT THAT IS
NEEDED FOR THAT- ARE MOVING
FORWARD. WE ALSO PUT FOR POSTAL
TO GET MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
INTEGRATION STATEWIDE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO SEPARATE
CONTRACTS WITH FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARTS TO ARE MEANT.
TO YOU DOORS. THE FOR KATE THIS
AN ACTUAL CREATE. MINISH BURDEN
ON OUR- AND THE STATE TO BE ON
AND ARE PER. AS A WORKING OVER
A FIVE YEAR PLAN TO INTEGRATE
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SIR. BY TRADE LEVEL IN
SIGHT LEVEL AND TO EXTENT
POSSIBLE. WHERE APPROPRIATE AS
WE KNOW A LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE HAVE COLOR BRING MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER I'M DE NOW IT'S ME TO
PROVIDE BETTER CARE FOR THEM.
INSTANCES. SO THOSE ARE THE
MAIN PIECES THAT ARE. AM FOR
GUARDS THE HUMMER AT THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. ACCOUNT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON
STEPHANIE CLENDENIN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF COST AND I GONNA
FOCUS MY COM ON THE COMMUNITY
CLASS PILAR PROJECT. THE BUDGET
PER TO FOUR POINT SIX MILLION
IN BUDGET YOU AND A TOTAL OF
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS OVER SIX
YEARS. FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS TO IMPLEMENT
THE COMMUNITY CARE
COLLABORATIVE PILOT PROJECT.
THIS PROJECT IS AIMED AT
DEMONSTRATING STRATEGIES TO
TREAT AND HOUSE A HIGH RISK
HIGH NEEDS POPULATION
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE LIVING
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS WHO
ARE CYCLING IN AND OUT OF OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND IN
OUR STATE HI I'M HOSPITALS. I
DO FEEL IT NEED TO PROVIDE.
CONTEXT IN BACKGROUND AS TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE SEEN AT
THE DEPARTMENT THAT HAVE KIND
OF SHAPE THIS PROPOSAL. I'M IN
SO THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS TREAT INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE FOUND INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL AND- INDIVIDUAL WHO'S
BEEN DEEMED INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL AS SOMEONE WHO'S
BEEN ARRESTED FOR A CRIME. AND
FOUND. PORTANTINO I MENTAL ON
THAT THE ERROR TO UNDERSTAND
THE NATURE OF THE CHARGES
AGAINST THEM OR THEIR UNABLE TO
ASSIST IN THEIR THEIR COUNCIL
IN THEIR DEFENSE SO INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE FOUND INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL ON FELONY CHARGES
ARE TREATED AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS IN OUR
PROGRAMS AN INDIVIDUAL BILLS
WHO ARE FOUND INCOME TO STAND
TRIAL ON MISDEMEANOR A CHART
ARE TREATED IN AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL. RESTORING AN INDIVIDUAL
TO COMPETENT IS REALLY JUST
FOCUS ON STABILIZING THEIR
MENTAL ILLNESS AND- ADDRESS AND
TEACHING THEM PROCESSES AND THE
ROLES OF THE COURT AND THEN
WHAT'S A RESTORED A COMPETENCY
WE RETURN THEM BACK TO THE-
COUNTY IN JAIL AND TO COURT TO
PROCEED THROUGH THEIR DUE
PROCESS IF IT DOES GET HARD OF.
THE ERROR LINE MEANT ONUS ARE
THE NATE THIS OF COMING THE
DEPARTMENT. WHICH OVER THE-
SENATE SIGNIFICANT IN IN THE OF
AND WHO AND ROOF TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND WE'VE BEEN
TAKING A THE OF REALLY ENJOY A
THIS BY JUST BUILDING MORE
CAPACITY TO RESTORE INDIVIDUALS
THE COMPETENCY TO RETURN THEM
BACK TO COURT- AND THAT DOESN'T
ALSO DOESN'T GET TO THE ROOT OF
THE PROBLEM LAST YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND FOCUS ON.
GEN PROBE. I TRIED TO GET
INDIVIDUALS BACK INTO COMMUNITY
SETTINGS AND THIS YEAR'S
PROPOSAL REALLY FOCUSES ON
ADDRESSING THIS PROBLEM I'M IN
IT IN A DIFFERENT WAY-
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FOUND IN
COMP IS STAND TRIAL MOST OF
THEM HAVE A MAJOR PSYCHOTIC
MOOD DISORDER AND HAD MULTIPLE
PRIOR ARRESTS. MANY ARE AND
SHELTERED HOMELESS AT THE TIME
OF THEIR ARREST- THEY'VE NOT
ACCESS THEIR SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES- IN THE SIX
MONTHS LEADING UP TO THEIR
REST. AND A GOOD LOOKING OUT
THEIR ARREST REPORTS REFLECTS
THAT MANY OF THEIR ARRESTS ARE
REALLY AT THE ROOT OF THE
CONDITION OF THEIR HOME THIS IN
THE CONTEXT SYMPTOMS. SO WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING TO THIS VERY
SPECIFIC POPULATION IN AN- THE
PROPOSAL TO STOP THE SIX YEAR
PILOT. ACROSS CAN. I'M OKAY
COME IS THAT REFER SOME OF THE
HIGH RATE OF INCOME TO AND TRY.
I'M INDIVIDUALS OUR GOVERNMENT.
IN COOKING THEM TO MAIN COME TO
THE PROPOSAL- THE FIRST IS BY.
MEANS ANI'S. DEBATE I READ.
ROOMS DIVISION IS FOUND IN COMP
STATE TRIAL ON FELONY TO. AND
THEN THE SECOND IS PROVIDE TEAR
FINANCE AND SENT TO I AM SET IN
THIS DAY BEEN. FOR THE COUNTIES
REACH AND- NOT ONLY THE NOW OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE REFERRED TO
THE DEPARTMENT BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ULTIMATELY ARRESTED AND DEAN
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
OVERALL. SO REALLY AS THE FOCUS
IS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE- ARRESTED.
IDENTIFIES TRY TO. IMPLEMENT
AND A DEMONSTRATE STRATEGIES I
HAVE FOR- REDUCING THE RATE OF
ARRESTS AND REPRESSIVE THIS TO
A POPULATION. INCENTIVIZING
BILLING A CONTINUUM OF CARE IN
THE COUNTY TO TREAT THIS
POPULATION AND DEMONSTRATING
STRATEGIES TO ADD TO TREAT AND
HOUSES POPULATION IN THE
COMMUNITY. SO I MAY BEGIN IF
THAT'S OKAY- AND I'LL GO IN
REVERSE ORDER JUST TO. ON THE
TRANSPARENT EARLIER YOU WOULD
ALLUDED TO THREE COUNTIES THAT
HAVE THE HIGHEST OF REFERRALS
RISE TEASE WHICH THREE COUNTIES
ARE THOSE. AYE WE'RE STILL IN
GOOD WORKING WITH THOSE
COUNTIES AND TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE INTERESTED SO WE
HAVEN'T REALLY DISCLOSE WHO
THEY ARE JUST YET FAIR ENOUGH-
SOME MOVEMENT TO JC PERFECT.
END UP FIRST CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR NEW POST IT'S- NICE TO
HAVE SOMEONE WHO SPENDS TIME IN
THE VALLEY I BELIEVE YOUR KERN
MEDICAL CENTER AND I'M QUITE
INTERESTED IN. CAL CAME IN- IF
I CANNOT I'D LIKE TO ACTUALLY
CALL IT MH SEE A- MEDI CAL
HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
THE LA- HAS HELPED ME TO SURE
GET THEIR IT'S EASIER. IF WE
CAN JUST OF ONE ACRONYM AND
STICK WE ARE WORKING ON THAT.
BUT I BRING IT UP BECAUSE I'M-
I THINK IT'S QUITE NOVEL AND
LONG OVER DUE FOR US TO MAKE
SOME OF THESE REFORMS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND- REALLY
DO APPRECIATE HOW YOU'RE
HELPING US TO BREAK UP MANY OF
THE SILOS AND FUNDING STREAMS
AND- THINK THAT THE ENHANCED
CARE MANAGEMENT AS WELL AS IN
LIEU OF SERVICES WILL. HELP US
TO SAVE MONEY IN THE LONG RUN-
BY HELPING TO MEET PEOPLE'S.
TRUE NEEDS AND SO I APPRECIATE
THE- EFFORT THAT WAS PUT INTO.
CRAFTING SOMETHING THIS LARGE
AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN. HELP TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT WORKS AND SO AND THAT'S
WHERE I WANT TO COME BACK IF I
COULD TO JENNIFER TORIA. YOU
HAD ALLUDED TO A REGION
EMPLOYING A BEST PRACTICE AND I
THINK THAT THE- C. A. H. S. IS.
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WAS THE
FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY POOL
IN LOS ANGELES AND SO WAS
HOPING THAT YOU COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT THERE WAS A RAND
STUDY THAT WAS PER. INSTALL FOR
WILL HELP PEOPLE. WHAT THE
RESULTS OF THAT STUDY WERE AND
WHY IT'S A GOOD. EXAMPLE FOR US
TO LOOK AT ABOUT WHAT'S
POSSIBLE BECAUSE IF WE'RE GOING
TO SELECT THAT AS WHAT COULD
HAPPEN TO OUR REGION WE SHOULD
EXPLAIN. WHY IT WAS IDENTIFIED
AS THE BEST PRACTICE AND NOT TO
START THEIR- YEAH SO LOS
ANGELES IS NOT THE ONLY- REGION
IN THE STATE OR AREA IN THE
STATE THAT HAS- EMPLOYED SUCH A
PRACTICE I BELIEVE THERE'S ALSO
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND A FEW
OTHERS AS WELL. EXCUSE ME ALL
OF THESE JURISDICTIONS THEY
WERE DOING- SOMETHINGS THAT ARE
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
AND SOME THAT ARE DIFFERENT- SO
SOME OF THE SIMILARITIES ARE
THE ARE THE FLEXIBILITY OF THE
FUNDING AND ALSO ANOTHER
SIMILARITY- IT. IN MANY CASES
THE BLENDING IN BRICK BEING OF
MULTIPLE FUNDS SURCES- AND
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
HOPE TO REPLICATE- THE IDEA
BEING THAT. EXCESS FULL ABOUT
THOUGHT IS THAT IT ALLOWS. BOTH
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES AND ALSO
ALLOWS TO HAVE- FEWER BARRIERS
BASED ON THE RESTRICT ANY
INDIVIDUAL FUND SOURCE BECAUSE
YOU CAN MIX THE FUNDS AS-
THIRTY INDIVIDUAL PER TING TO
YEAR HAS. SEVERAL DIFFERENT
NEEDS AND WHAT FUND SOURCE CAN
BE UTILIZED TO MEET THAT NEED
BUT ANOTHER STORY. NICE TO MEET
DIFFERENT. YOU CAN MIX TOGETHER.
AND SEEM TO THE- AN OR PERSON.
I BUT BEHIND THIS. IS AT THE
ENTITIES CAN IN NETWORK TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE MEETING THEIR NEEDS.
ASSEMBLY WAY WE INTEND TO ALLOW
FOR FLEXIBILITY AND GAP FILLING.
TO TAKE IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL OF
COULD ABOUT THE RAND STUDY IN
WHY I THAT PANEL IT IT IT
SHOULD THE RESIDENT ON. THAT
EVERY DOLLAR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND THEY WERE SAVING A DOLLAR
TWENTY AND- OTHER HEALTH CARE
RELATED COSTS IN THE OUR VISITS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE. AND I DON'T THINK THAT
FULLY CAPTURES AS WELL. COSTS
THAT COULD BE FROM JAILS OR
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN PRISON AS
WELL AND SO I. LOOK TO THAT IS
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF HOW WE-
SHOULD BE. LOOKING AT HOW WE-
SPEND OUR LIMITED RESOURCES IN
A WAY THAT BOTH EFFECTIVE AND
ACCOUNTABLE SO. WITH THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GO AHEAD
JIM THIS FROM DESTROYER- SO
WHERE WE CHANGING COURSE FROM
FUNDING CITIES COUNTIES AND
FEEL SEIZE TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR FLEXIBLE FUN
WITHOUT KNOWING MORE DETAILS
WHO IS IN CHARGE. THE REGION'S
ALSO HOW DO WE KNOW THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE DOESN'T WORK BECAUSE
YOU GUYS SIGNED OFF ON HAPPENED
LAST YEAR. WHEN HE HASN'T BEEN
GIVEN OUT SO WE HAVE NO IDEA IF
CAPS EFFECTIVE OR NOT AND NOW
WE'RE CHANGING COURSE. SO IT'S
I MEAN HOW DO YOU RECONCILE
THOSE IT SO I DO I THINK YOU
HEARD THE GOVERNOR SAY EARLIER
TODAY THAT HE BELIEVES WE STILL
DO NEED TO INNOVATE AND THAT
THIS IS- BUILDING ON THE
SUCCESS OF THOSE PROGRAMS I
DON'T THINK THAT WE ARE- SAYING
THAT THERE IS- HOW DO YOU. HOW
DO YOU HAVE SUCCESS THE PROGRAM
HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED. IF
THERE'S NO SUCCESS RIGHT NOW.
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE ARE ARE
BEING INFORMATION ANYONE SPEAK
FOR THE ENTITY THAT ARE
ADMINISTERING THEM BUT I WILL
SAY THAT- SO. ON OUR- THIS IS
THE- ALRIGHT. IN FOR HE FOR
EXAMPLE AND IN PRIOR YEARS AS
WELL SO- IN THIS CASE WE ARE
SAYING WE WANT TO USE A NEW
MODEL YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THAT THIS IS INTENDED TO BE AN
INNOVATION AND A NEW MODEL
HAVING SAID THAT IT'S MEANT TO
BUILD ON THE COLLABORATIONS
THAT ALREADY EXIST SO THE FUND
PURPOSES ARE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT. STRUCTURE IS
DIFFERENT BUT THE LOCAL
PARTNERS ARE THE SAME LOCAL
PARTNER NEED TO BE INVOLVED IN
ALL OF THE- MACINNES. SO WE
EXPECT THAT THE REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS WILL COLLABORATE
WITH CITIES COUNTIES CEO SEES
AND OTHER LOCAL ENTITIES- IN
SOME CASES THE REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS MAY BE THOSE
ENTITIES- SO THAT IS NOT. A
DEPARTURE OR A CHANGE IN
COURSE- THE FINDING AND HOW IT
FLOWS AND HOW THE
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISMS ARE
THEN. IMPLEMENTED. IT'S BEEN UP
AND RUNNING MONIES
MISATTRIBUTED THERE NO DETAILS
YET ON THAT. AND I'LL SEE HAVE
HASN'T DONE THAT'S WHAT'S JUST.
I MEAN IT'S A LOT OF TALK. YOU
KNOW AND- BUT WE STILL HAVE
NOTHING TO. SUBSTANTIAL TO MOVE
HONORED TO MAKE OUR DECISIONS
BASED UPON THAT. YEAH WE
BELIEVE THIS WILL BE A
SUCCESSFUL MODEL OF ADDING
AGAIN ANOTHER GAP FILLER SO
WOULD HE BEEN HACKED AND OTHER
RESOURCES DO EXIST LOCALLY WE
HAVE FEDERAL FUNDING STREAMS.
AT THESE REGIONAL ENTITIES
GOING TO NEED TO ASSESS WHAT
ARE THEY ALREADY ABLE TO COVER
FROM EACH OF THOSE FUNDS
SOURCES AND WHAT IS MISSING.
AND THE FLEXIBILITY THAT ADDED
HERE THEY WILL BE PRIORITIZING
LOCALLY WITH THEIR PARTNERS TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THESE
FUNDS ARE BEST USED FOR SO ALL
OF THE FUNDS. WILL GO TO
IMPROVE AND CRITICAL YOU SIT.
WITH IN ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM.
THEY WILL HAVE DIFFERENT
MECHANISMS AND ACCOUNTABILITY
METRICS ASSOCIATED WITH THEM
BASED ON THE STUDENTS TO
ADDRESS ARE THERE ANY CHANGES
TO EARLY ACTION. THERE OCCURRED
AFTER THEIR- IS SO WHICH WE
EXPECT TO SEE MORE DETAILS ON
NEW ITEMS DISCUSSED TODAY.
INCLUDING STRIKE TEAMS AND
ONGOING WRAPPING SORT THIS. AT
ALL APPOINT WITHIN THE EVER
TALKED ABOUT AS AN ASSISTANT
FUND HE'S THERE'S NO FUNDING
STREAM FOR IT. AND JUST THE WAY
THINGS HAVE GONE I'M NOT SURE
THIS APPETITE FOR A TAX
INCREASE. BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S BEEN A- REQUIRE A
SUCCESSFUL MY OF MONEY. FOR
REAL. AND HOW DO WE GET THERE
SO THERE'S LOTS ON THAT SURE I
AM SO THERE IS SOME ALLOWANCE
FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
RENTAL SUBSIDIES WITHIN THE
FINE BUT I THINK YOU'RE
REFERENCING THE GOVERNOR'S
REMARKS ABOUT THE ON GOING.
RIGHT AND I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD O
WHAT HE ALREADY SHARED WITH YOU
IN TERMS OF THE TIMING OR
DETAILS OF WHEN THAT WILL
HAPPEN I KNOW WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT
BUT- WILL NEED TO- GOT. WITHIN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND
CONTINUED WORK WITH ALL OF YOU
TO FOLLOW UP ON HIS PARKS THANK
YOU. WHAT THANK. I'M CONCERNING
THE AT THE BOARDING CARE HOMES-
THEY'RE GOING OUT OF BUSINESS
CAN YOU PROVIDE SOME MORE
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON HOW YOU
PLAN TO DISTRIBUTE OF THOSE
FUNDS YEAH SO- AGAIN THE FUNDS
THROUGH THE ACCESS TO HOUSING
AND SERVICES FUND WILL GO TO
THEY'LL BE ALLOCATED BY REGION
AND THEN REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS WILL MAKE A
LOCAL PLAN FOR THEIR REGION
ABOUT HOW THEY INTEND TO USE
THE FUNDS ONE OF THE ALLOWABLE
USES IS TO USE THEM TO
STABILIZE BOARDING CARE
FACILITIES. WHICH IRAQ I'M- OUR
DEFINITION OF BOARDING CARE
FACILITIES WE ARE THE LICENSING
ENTITY FOR THESE FACILITIES AS
WELL AS ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES AND RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY- AND
I THINK WHAT WE MIGHT ENVISION
FOR EXAMPLE IS AN OPERATING
SUBSIDY. OR CAPITAL SUPPORTS TO
COLLAPSE ONE TIME INVESTMENT-
THAT MAY COME THEN WITH A RED
RENTAL SET ASIDE AND YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF HOW GREAT THE NEED IS
TO SUPPORT THESE- IT'S IT IS
DIFFICULT TO PUT AN EXACT
METRIC ON IT WE CERTAINLY HEAR
ANECDOTALLY. THAT THERE ARE
CLOSER IS AS- AND SOME OF THEM
ARE CONCENTRATED IN CERTAIN
REGIONS AGAIN AS THE LICENSING
ENTITY WE HEAR FROM OUR LEFT
AND SEE SOMETIMES WHO ARE
CLOSING OR WHO REQUIRE A TWO.
THIS AND WE'VE HAD COVERAGE
WITH THEM I YOU WILL ALSO BE.
FROM SOME OF THE COUNTY FOLKS
WHO HAVE RAISE THE STEP IS A
CONCERN THAT DAVE'S LOCALLY AT
CHAIR. OUR CONCERN AND INTEREST
IN. AND DO YOU THINK IT'S
FEASIBLE TO USE A PORTION OF
THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
TO GIVE PUBLIC FIRST REFUSE A
LARGE PURCHASE. THE IN SEASON
GOING OF. I WE ALLOW WERE DID
OF A FOR HOUSE AND WE DO ABOUT
STABILIZING BORN HERE IS I
DON'T KNOW IF WE'VE BEEN QUITE
SO SPECIFIC TO FIGURE THAT
PIECE OUT YET WHEN WE DEVELOP
OUR REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS AND
WHEN THE REGIONAL ADMINISTRATOR
SUBMIT THEIR PLANS THERE WILL
BE QUITE A BIT MORE DETAIL
ABOUT EACH OF THE ELEMENTS THAT
I. DESCRIBED THANK YOU. IF WE
CAN WILL DO CHAIR TING AND THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER FIRST.
SO I DON'T KNOW OF IT SO. IN A
SPECIAL NEEDS COMMUNITY- WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT. MEDI CAL ARM OR
TEND TO CAL. CAN WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT DIFFERENT
PARAMETERS AND- ONE EIGHT
EIGHT. AN INDIVIDUAL IDT COMES
INTO THE DENTIST OR THROUGH
THAT THAT PROCESS THEY HAVE TO
BE REFERRED BY A DOCTOR TO GET
SOME SCENES. MOST INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE. TO GO TO A DENTIST
HAVE TO BE GO TO ANESTHESIA.
THAT'S NOT COVERED BY THE-
PROCESS OF FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND. THAT'S A BIG
COMPONENT FOR SOME OF THESE
FAMILIES A IS THAT THAT. IN THE
HEALTH COMPONENT THROUGH
MEDICAL OR DENTAL I'M SO A MEDI
CAL DOES COVER DENTAL
ANASTASIA- TODAY AND SO WE CAN
GET YOU INFORMATION- REGARDING
WHAT IS OR IS NOT COVERED IN
THE IN THE PROGRAM- BOTH ON
CERTAIN PIECES ON THE DENTAL
SIDE IN CERTAIN PIECES ON THE
MEDI CAL PORTION OF THEM KERR.
BONTA ARE THE HOW DID YOU
INFORMATION THANK YOU ON THAT
AND I WILL FOLLOW UP THE YEAH
THE OTHER ONE IS THE OFTEN THE
MORE THAN THE- CAL ROOM THREE.
SO I'VE BEEN IN THIS LIST FOR
GOING ON A YEARS. AND NEVER BE
ADJUSTED ACCORDING. A WE HAVE
DOCTORS THE WON'T SEE PATIENTS
WHO ARE IN DIRE NEED. IN RURAL
AREAS OR ANY AREA REALLY. HOW
ARE WE GOING TO. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT. YOU KNOW SERVING THE
HOMELESSNESS SERVING THE IN
GENERAL. BUT WE HAVE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ACTUALLY JUST
NOT SERVED BY BY PHYSICIANS
BECAUSE THIS WILL TAKE THIS
REIMBURSEMENT. WHAT PROCESSES
IN PLACE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
I'M SO THE DEPARTMENT- AND- WE
LOOK AT IT I GUESS IT DEPENDS
ON WHAT YOU'R NOT MANAGED CARE
FEE FOR SERVICE SO. WE HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT DELIVERY SYSTEMS ON
85% OF OUR BENEFICIARIES ARE IN
THE MANAGED CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM WHERE WE PAY OUR MANAGED
CARE PLANS A CAPITATED RATE- IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO OVERSEE THAT
THE FUL BENEFIT THAT IS ON
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY- BOTH THE
ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT IN LIEU
OF SERVICES ARE WOULD BE ON
THAT PARTICULAR PIECE IN WHAT
WE'RE ABOUT FOR THE- FOR THE
HOMELESS. AND IN. WE HAVE.
TOOLS THE ARE. DONE ON A
SCHEDULE ARE DIFFERENT PIECES.
OF SO I'M AT THE THERE IS BEEN
A NUMBER OF EFFORTS MADE BY THE
DEPARTMENT WHETHER THAT'S
THROUGH PROP FIFTY SIX
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS FOR
PHYSICIANS AND DENTAL SERVICES.
ON THAT HAVE BEEN IN PLACE FOR
SOME TIME I'M TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE MAKING SURE PEOPLE OF
ADEQUATE ASK ACCESS TO SERVICES
WERE ALSO LOOKING AT ACCESS ON
A VERY REGULAR BASIS TO ENSURE
THAT. OUR BENEFICIARIES ARE
RECEIVING ADEQUATE ACCESS TO.
PREVENTIVE SERVICES- PRIMARY
CARE SERVICES SPECIALTY. PUBLIC
EVER IT MAY BE. IN THE
DEPARTMENT CONTENT WORK ON
THOSE THAT ARE. TO ARE YOU
WORKING WITH. IT IS A WHOLE
BECAUSE I'M SENIOR YOU SING
YOUR SAID THE FEES. ARE YEARS.
SETTING VIS. REIMBURSEMENTS
WHAT IF IT'S NOT ENOUGH. WHEN
IT COMES TO THE MANAGED CARE
SIDE WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
ACTUARIES IN ORDER TO SET A
RATES BASED ON HISTORICAL
UTILIZATION OF SERVICES- AND
THEN MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY REALLY SOUND TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO SERVICES-
AND SO WE'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO MEET WITH YOU AND TALK
THROUGH- OUR RATE SETTING
PROCESS WITH OUR FINANCE TEAM-
BUT THAT IS THE GOAL OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN HAVE ACCESS TO
SERVICES. I'M WE HAVE A GREAT
TO BE ABLE SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE PROGRAM WE
CENTURIES AGAIN I'M LOOKING FOR
STAKEHOLDER INPUT FROM THE
PHYSICIANS ARE ARE GIVERS ARE
YOU WORKING THEM BECAUSE
THEY'RE THE ONES COMPLAINING IT
WOULD BE TO KNOW IF THIS FROM
ON A MANAGE CARE. BETTER AND OR
WHETHER IT'S- THING ON THE
FIRST BESIDE. CERTAIN BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO BE A- DIFFERENT.
DEPEND ON WHICH DELIVERS SYSTEM
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN REGARDS
TO HOW WE OVERSEE DIFFERENT
PIECES- SO WOULD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU IN
REGARDS TO THOSE PIECES.
BECAUSE ON THE MANAGED CARE
SIDE IT IS A VERY KIND OF
COMPLICATED RATE SETTING
PROCESS WHERE- WE DO HIRE
OUTSIDE ACTUARIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S- THAT IT'S A SOUND
RIGHT TO COVER. THE IN PATIENT
THE OUT PAY SERVICES WHATEVER
THEY ARE POSSIBLE FOR COVERING-
A BET MEDIC COMPLICATED BECAUSE
WE HAVE SOMEWHAT A. B. A
SEPARATED SYSTEM. I'M CERTAIN
P. CARTELS A MENTAL HEALTH IS.
OUT SINCE USE THIS ORDER
SERVICES. DOUBT DENTAL IS. OUT
OF CONTRACT WAS A VARIETY OF A
KIND PIECES I JUST ASK FOR
EXAMPLE SO IT'S HARPER US IN
THIS I KNOW WHICH TYPES OF
PROVIDERS FOR ME TO BE OF THE
SPEAK TO THE DIFFERENT. I THINK
MAGNETS. BUT WOULD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO THROUGH WITH YOU COULD
I. THE PROVIDERS I'M GOING TO
VERY DEPEND ON WHICH DELIVERS.
TALK. ROOM YEAH I'M LOOKING TO
FIND BUT I MAY ASK ONE AS WELL
SHIP AND PERSON CARE. ARE THEY
DO IS IT WHAT'S THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THEM-
WHAT'S DIFFERENT THE TERM THAT
NOTE THAT DISAPPEAR SO AND ONE
OF THE BIGGEST VALUES A WHOLE
PERSON CARE IS IT REQUIRES THAT
THE ENTITY BE WILLING TO TAKE
ON BOTH THE MEDICAL THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND THE
COORDINATION OF SOCIAL SERVICES
OR EVEN LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS- AND WE AS WE ROLL OUT
THE ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT
WHICH WOULD BE KIND OF ONGOING
STANDARD ASIAN AND BENEFIT PART
FOR- WHOLE PERSON CARE WE WILL
HAVE TO LOOK AT INTERACTIONS
WITH OTHER SERVICES INCLUDING
WHAT BE. COULD BE POTENTIALLY
BEING PROVIDED IT DELIVERS I'M
WE HAVE A STEP OF VULNERABLE
POPULATION WHICH WE CONSIDER TO
BE OUR TARGET POPULATIONS WITH
ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO HAVE A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS- SUBS
ARE A SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICE ARE AND MAKE NO SAYS-
SUB BRING CHRONIC DISEASES THEY
MAY MARK PAUL WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH THE BAY. BASS WE DO WANT
MANAGED CARE PLANS BE ABLE
CONTRACT. HERE'S TO AB INBEV
CARE MANAGED PROVIDER HOWEVER.
THEY BE WILLING TO TAKE THE
RISK. OF THAT A- QUE MANAGEMENT.
AND WE WILL TO CORDON ALL OF
THOSE SERVICES WHETHER IT'S THE
HOUSING SERVICES THE SOCIAL
SERVICES AND OR THE MEDICAL
SERVICES IN ADDITION TO WHAT
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING. ON AND
SO WE WILL BE EVALUATING WHAT
IS PROVIDED IN WHETHER IT'S THE
FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIP MET
MHSAA TO EVALUATE AND- THAT
WE'RE NOT DUPLICATING ACROSS-
VARIOUS AREAS. BUT WE ALSO WANT
THEM TO BE A CRITICAL PARTNER
AND PROVIDER IN THE SPACE IF IT
WERE PEOPLE TELL US COMFORTABLE
TO RECEIVE THEIR SERVICES. AND
HELLO BEFORE- CHAIR TEEN I.
WANT TO- ROAD MAP A LITTLE BIT
TO WITHIN SUB ONE WE WILL BE
TRYING TO TALK ABOUT. YOUR.
SUPPORT SAYS WELL AS
DISPARITIES ON. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE OUR
MENTAL HEALTH POPULATION
MIRRORS OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
POPULATION AND- THOSE
DISPARITIES NEED TO BE CALLED
OUT AND- ADDRESSED EXPLICITLY
IN SO- JUST LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE CONVERSATIONS CHARTING.
THANK YOU- JUST A QUICK
QUESTION FOR MISS TRIED YET
MENTIONED ALLOCATION BY REGION
GIVE ANY SENSE ON HOW. YOU'RE
GONNA PRIORITIZE FUNDING BY
REGION AND- I AM THE TRAILER
BILL CALLS FOR VERY SPECIFIC-
AT MEASURES IN ORDER TO GET TO
THOSE- ALLOCATIONS SO THE FIRST
ONE IS THE POINT IN TIME COUNT
FOR HOMELESSNESS IS THE SECOND
ONE IS THE- BRENT BURDEN OF
INDIVIDUALS AND A COMMUNITY THE
THIRD IS. THE JOURNAL HOUSING
NEEDS ASSESSMENT AND THEN THE
FINAL ONE IS RACIAL EQUITY. I'M
WHICH WERE DEFINING AS
DISPROPORTION ALIKI AMONG
CERTAIN POPULATIONS GREAT THANK
INDEED GIVE ME I'D SINCE I. HOW
MANY REGIONS ARE YOU. THINKING
OUT WE HAVE NOT PUT FORWARD YET
ANNE AM SPECIFIC IDENTIFICATION
OF THE REGIONS BUT WE ARE
WORKING ON IT AND DO HOPE THAT
WE CAN SHARE MORE WITH YOU
SOON. OKAY THANK YOU. WHAT.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION ON THE
REGION'S BECAUSE PART OF THE
QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS WHAT IS
THAT GOING TO LOOK LIK IS THAT
CAN YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR ALSO
ON ON THE BUSINESS SIDE HAS HIS
WHOLE REGIONS RISE TOGETHER-
INITIATIVE THAT HE'S WORKING ON
SO ARE WE GONNA TIE CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW IT'S GONNA BE THE SAME
OR IS IT GONNA BE SPLIT- AND
THEN. ALSO YOU KNOW I HAVE HAD
MEETINGS WITH MY COUNTY. HUMAN
SERVICES DIRECTOR IN AND THEIR
TEAM. AND HOW MUCH ARE WE GONNA
WORK WITH THEM WITHIN THEIR
REGIONS AND YOU KNOW OF THE
PLANS THAT I'M HERE IN OUR YOU
KNOW. FIVE YEAR PILOT PROJECT
PROGRAMS. SO. YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE YEARS IS.
WILL WANT TO GET A PILOT
PROJECT GOING WILL WANT TO GET
SOMETHING SET UP AND THEN IT'LL
TAKE A YEAR TWO YEARS JUST TO
HIRE THE PEOPLE STARTED. AND SO
THAT'S MY CONCERN HERE IS. JUST
YOU KNOW WE HAVE EXISTING
THINGS. EXISTING TOOLS. WHY ARE
WE FIXING THE MECHANICS OF THE
PROGRAM'S. TO MOVE FORWARD
BECAUSE THAT THAT'S MY BIGGEST
THING IS WE'VE GOT A LIKE I
SAID EARLIER IT'S THE MECHANICS
THAT GO INTO THIS. AND MAKING
SURE THAT THOSE PEOPLE ARE ARE
GOING TO BE THERE IN THOSE
POSITIONS. THAT EVERYBODY'S
WORKING TOGETHER. A AND THAT
IT'S REFRESHING TO HEAR THAT WE
DON'T WANT IT TO BE YOU KNOW.
DUPLICATED IN MULTIPLE PARTS
BECAUSE WE SEE THAT OVER AND
OVER AND OVER SPECIALLY IN THE
HUMAN SERVICES BASIC SPECIALLY
WITH OUR SOCIAL WORKERS. WHERE
YOU KNOW YOU YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
SOCIAL WORKERS WORKING WITH ONE
FAMILY ON DIFFERENT PIECES
INSTEAD OF ONE SOCIAL WORKER
COVERING DOWN ON THE WHOLE
FAMILY THE COVER EVERYTHING- A
AND IT'S BEEN A CONVERSATION
WE'VE HAD MULTIPLE TIMES WITHIN
THIS COMMITTEE IS WILL YOU KNOW
WHY WE HAVE SO MANY SOCIAL
WORKERS WHEN WE HAVE A SOCIAL
WORKER SHORTAGE. NOT GOING
POSTAL WORKER PER FAMILY TAKING
CARE OF ALL THE DIFFERENT
ISSUES. AND REALLY OF I'M I'M
JUST CURIOUS TO SEE HOW WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THIS TOGETHER LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING YOU KNOW THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE GONNA HAVE-
BECAUSE THESE PIECES HAVE TO
FIT BUT THIS IDEA OF OKAY GREAT
FIVE YEARS FROM NOW WILL FIVE
YEARS FROM NOW HALF THE PEOPLE
IN THIS ROOM ARE GOING TO BE
OUT OFFICE. AND THERE'S GONNA
BE ANOTHER. GOVERNOR COMING AND
SELL IT'S GREAT TO KICK THE CAN
DOWN THE ROAD TO WHEN YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO BE HERE. VOIGTS
WE'VE GOT I'M SURE THESE THINGS
ARE PUT TOGETHER. NOW AND USE
THE TOOLS THAT WE HAVE ON THE
TABLE NOW. AND SHARPEN THEM AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY.
DO THESE THINGS BECAUSE IT.
WELL A LOT OF CONCERN WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT THE AD IN FIVE YEARS
WE'RE GOING TO RE EVALUATE A
PILOT PROJECT. THAT DOESN'T GET
THE JOB DONE NOW. ED WE'VE ONLY
SEEN THANKS FOR AGGRESSIVELY
GET WORSE. SO WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT THAT PIECE AND WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT. THIS PIECE
WHERE WE GET THIS 60% OF OUR
COUNTY JAIL POPULATION. THAT
THERE BECAUSE OF MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES THAT'S
NOT WHERETHEY NEED TO BE IT'S
MORE EXPENSIVE FOR THEM TO BE
THERE THEY'RE HAVING A CONTRACT
OUT THE SERVICES. WHICH ONLY
INCREASES THE COST. SO WE'VE
GOT TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THEY
NEED TO GO. BECAUSE IT IS IT IS
THE LESSER CRIMES IT'S NOT. THE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
NECESSARILY IT'S A WHOLE OTHER
PIECE. AND THE GOVERNOR
MENTIONED RE LOOKING AT PROP
SIXTY THREE. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME AND TELL WE REEVALUATE
SOME OF THE CONDITIONS AND PROP
47-57. TO LOOK AT. YOU KNOW
WHAT'S A CRIME AS FAR AS THE
DRUG SIDE GOES IN THESE THINGS
GO. WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT
BECAUSE HE TALKED ABOUT.
LOOKING AT A WAY WHERE WE CAN
KIND OF HOLD THEM AND FORCE
THEM INTO TREATMENT. WHAT IS
ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE WITHOUT A
CRIMINAL SIDE. THERE IS WE HAVE
TO DO. IS MENTION EARLIER YOU
YOU CAN'T DO A SEVENTY TWO HOUR
HOLD. YOU CAN'T HAVE THEM COME
IN AND THEN GO BACK OUT INTO
THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING BACK INTO THE SAME
POSITION. THE SAME PEOPLE
AROUND THEM THAT GOT THEM INTO
THE MESS IN THE FIRST PLACE SO
WITHOUT THAT TREATMENT CENTER.
WHERE THEY CAN GO TO GET THE
HELL. N. DAD'S GOING TO BE KEY
TO THIS WHOLE THING. IN IN A
WE'VE SEEN A WE FOR THE
PROFESSIONALS TALK ABOUT ALL
THE STUDIES EVERYTHING ELSE
SHOWS. YOU'VE GOTTA BE ABLE TO
GET THEM TREATMENT AND GET
FOLKS BACK ON THEIR FEET. NOT
JUST DROP ON BACK OFF. ON THE
STREET WHERE THEY WERE WITH THE
SAME MASS THAT THEY WERE AT.
THE UNIFICATION CLEAN FOR SHORT
PERIOD TIME THEY'RE GONNA GO
BACK TO THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
GOT A RELAPSE WE SEE IT TIME
AND TIME AGAIN. SO WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT SOMETHING BETTER AND
I'M- HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN DO
THAT THIS YEAR. SO ANY COMMENTS
THE ONLY THING I WOULD SAY I
JUST WANT CLEAR FIVE FOR THE
MEDICAL PIECES THEY WON'T BE
PILOTS WERE ACTUALLY
TRANSITIONING FROM WHAT HAS
BEEN CALLED OUR WHOLE PERSON
CARE PILOTS INTO A STATEWIDE-
MANDATED BENEFIT SO WOULD BE
STANDARDIZED STATEWIDE AND
WOULD BE MOVING OUT OF THAT
KIND OF PILOT PHASE INTO A MORE
SUSTAINABLE LONG TERM- SOLUTION
FOR BOTH ENHANCE CARE
MANAGEMENT AND THE AND LOVE
SERVICES SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT POINT IN REGARDS
TO THOSE. I'M THAT IS ALSO TRUE
FUNDED AND IT'S NOT INTENDED TO
BE A PILOT AND AS YOU HEARD THE
GOVERNOR'S- ASK OUR INTENTION
IS FOR EARLY ACTION BECAUSE OUR
EFFORT IS TO AS AS SOON AS WE
RECEIVE AUTHORIZATION. TO HAVE
THOSE FUNDS AND BE READY TO HIT
THE STREET AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
THIS SUMMER- SO WE SHARE YOUR
SENSE OF URGENCY TO MOVE
QUICKLY- AND WHEN WE DO FOLLOW
UP WITH THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE REGION'S I THINK YOU WILL
SEE THAT WE ARE TRYING TO BE
VERY INTENTIONAL ABOUT LOOKING
AT. EXISTING STRUCTURES AND
RESPECTING CERTAIN BOUNDARIES
AND PARTNERSHIPS THAT ALREADY
DO EXIST AND BUILDING UPON SO.
WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO TALKING
MORE WITH YOU ABOUT THAT AS
WELL. MR OIL FOR YOU TALKED
ABOUT DSS DEVELOPING THEIR
PLAN- YOU MENTIONED SEVERAL
TIMES IS LEGISLATURE INCLUDING
NECESSARY. AND COME BACK FOR
INPUT OBVIOUSLY WERE A- PART OF
FUNDING SO. THAT JUST A PLAN
JUST BY DSS ONLY HERE- IT'S SO
IT'S SO THE LEGISLATURE
CERTAINLY INVOLVED OBVIOUSLY
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND THE
CREATION OF THE TRAILER BILL
BUT IN ADDITION WE HAVE-
SPECIFIED IN THE TRAILER BILL
THAT WITH RESPECT TO THE RFP
PROCESS THERE'S GOING TO BE
STAKEHOLDER CONSULTATIONS. THEY
WILL INCLUDE LEGISLATIVE STAFF
THERE'S ONE THAT'S ACTUALLY
BEING PLANNED FOR. NEXT WEEK-
AND THEN AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE R. F. P. PROCESS WE
WILL. WE WILL BE CONTINUING- TO
WORK WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF.
WHAT'S INTERESTING LEGISLATIVE
STAFFERS KNOW WHERE OF THE ONE
NEXT WEEK. I IT'S ACTUALLY AS I
SAID BEING PLANNED AS IN THE
INVITATIONS ARE- AT BE DRAFTED
NOW AND SHOULD. BE A TIME TO
YOUR STAFF SHORTLY. OKAY MANY
EIGHT. THIS EXPO CREATION OF AN
AGENCY. S. LOOSE LEAF WAS ON
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS. IS A
MAKES SENSE TO PLACE THIS AND
SAYS. WE'LL LIST ACTUALLY
CONTROLLED IN THE- HOUSE. AND
ALMOST. BIRDS ARE ONE AGENCY
SAID. I'M WITH RUSSIAN UP. WE
THINK IT IT'S A PLACE TO CINDY
FAST BECAUSE WE ALL. RATED
NUMBER OF THE STAY FIFTEEN
PROGRAM AND BE WE ALREADY. AN
M. OF TARGET HOT HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS AND WE
THINK AS AS YOU'VE SORT OF SEEN
BY THIS PANEL HERE TODAY THAT
IS A PART OF THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE OTHER
PIECES THAT ARE SO BEING
PROPOSED THAT THERE IS AT A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO BOTH
THOSE HOUSING AND THE
CORRESPONDING SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES. BETTER NECESSARY TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO BE STABILIZED
TO HEALTH THE MYSTERY BEEN PLAN
ON CONSULTING EVERYTHING. UNDER
ONE. ROOF I'M AT SPEAK TO THAT
I KNOW THE COUNCIL IS DOING
SOME WORK ON LONG TERM
PLANNING. AND I CAN'T SPEAK TO
WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO RELEASE
THAT INFORMATION. OKAY THANK
YOU. HAPPY TO TRY TO GET BACK
TO YOU. COUPLE FALL FALL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN- SOCIAL
SERVICES AND HOMELESSNESS SO AT
FIRST A QUESTION FOR DSS I KNOW
THAT THE PROPOSAL IS TRAVELING
SERVICES ADMINISTERED BY DSS TO
RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO KEEP
PEOPLE HOUSED BUT THERE'S
NOTHING THE PROPOSAL THAT
EXPLAINS HOW THE COORDINATION
WOULD OCCUR COULD YOU TALK
ABOUT THAT. YEAH IT'S ACTUALLY
NOT JUST THE SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED BY DFS THOUGH THOSE
ARE CERTAINLY THERE SO AN
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THAT WE
WOULD EXPECT THAT AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY COME TO OUR
ATTENTION WHO COULD QUALIFY FOR
SOME OF THE BENEFITS PROGRAMS
THAT WE OPERATE THROUGH THE
SAFETY NET SO FOR EXAMPLE SS I
SS P. OR CAL WORKS AS A FAMILY-
THAT THEY WOULD BE CONNECTED
WITH THOSE BENEFITS PROGRAMS IF
THEY NOT. ARE NOT ALREADY AND
THAT THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO
AND HAVE THE FAMILY INCOME AND
OTHER SUPPORT SERVICES THAT
MIGHT HELP TO STATE IS THEM
ALONG WITH THE HOUSING. BUT THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF SERVICES
AND VISION IN THE LANGUAGE ARE
TENANTS THE SUPPORT SERVICES SO
THAT'S HOUSING NAVIGATION.
LEGAL SERVICES IS THAT MY EIGHT
OUT TO RETAIN HOUSING LA LOWER.
SERVICE LIKE THAT SET DSS IT'S
NUMBER OF HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
CERTAIN TARGET. SO PERHAPS
FAMILY OF THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM IN OUR IN FAMILY'S HOME
PRO OR THE COW WORKS HOW SAID.
PROGRAM FOR WITH CHILDREN ARE
LOW INCOME. SO WE ALSO MIGHT
CONNECTS PEOPLE THROUGH THOSE
KINDS OF PROGRAMS AB DEPENDING
UPON THEIR NEEDS. AND THE
RELATED TO THAT I KNOW- THERE
LOTS OF PROGRAMS CAL WORKS FOOD
STAMPS MEDICAIDOUT WHERE
THERE'S AN OVERLAP BETWEEN
THOSE RECIPIENTS IN INDIVIDUALS
THAT COULD BECOME HOMELESS-
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT WHETHER COUNTY SHOULD BE
REQUIRED TO ASK PEOPLE ABOUT
THEIR HOUSING STATUS TO SORT
OF. INTEGRATE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. IS WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ARE ON THAT. I'M NOT
SURE IF WE'VE NECESSARILY
WAITING ON THAT SPECIFIC ASPECT
OF THE CONVERSATION I MEAN IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO US TO COLLECT
THE DATA THAT WE CAN WE'VE
TALKED THING. I SO THAT HOW IN
TIME IT'S OUR A VERY IMPORTANT
AS OF HOW. AT THE SAME I AM.
I'M PERHAPS PERFECT AND PERHAPS
THERE UNDER. AND WHAT ELSE HAVE
I'M PROXY MEANT IS THAT I SOME
OF GRAMM'S IN THE COUNTY SO WE
WORK WITH YOU WITHIN THEIR
CASELOAD TO TRY TO IDENTIFY
FOLKS. I BUT ARE HOPEFUL THAT
AS WE SORT OF PEOPLE THROUGH
THE SPACE. FIND THAT WE WILL
COLLECT TO DATE THAT IS. THAT
WHEN YOU ARE AT THE OLD UP A
BEAR. INSIDE. AND THE SOME SAY
RISK FROM. IN OF DEPENDING ON
HOW MANY OF THESE. SERVICES
THAT YOU OF. BILL THAT THESE
ARE INDEED. THAT ARE VERY
VULNERABLE TO HOMELESSNESS AS
YOU NOW ONE LAST QUESTION- I
THINK MANY OF US RESTRICTED DAY
BY GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S COMMENT
THAT HE WANTS DOCTORS TO BE
ABLE TO WRITE. PRESCRIPTIONS
FOR HOUSING- AS THE AUTHOR OF
THE HOUSING OF IT FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT WE HAVE-
VERY INTRIGUED BY THIS. I
THINK. THE QUESTION IS REALLY
HOW WOULD THIS HAPPEN AND
SPECIFICALLY- MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT CHANGES TO MEDICARE HOW
WOULD REQUIRE. MANAGED
PROVIDERS TO OFFER CIRCLE IN
LIEU FEES LIKE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE. CAPTION OCCASION
CENTERS THAT THE SERVICES-
HOUSING MISSING STAINING
SERVICES EXCEPT TRUCK. SEEMS
LIKE A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
STRUCTURAL REQUIREMENT TO SAY
THAT DOCTORS DOCTOR RAMBLE IS
THE WORLD. WOULD HAVE TO OR- BE
CALM EXPERTS AND HOW TO
NAVIGATE. HOUSING SYSTEMS HOW
HOW WOULD THIS HAPPEN. HOW THIS
ACTUALLY HAPPEN SHORES SO IT
REALLY IS UNDER ALTHOUGH I KNOW
DOCTOR. WILL BE ABLE TO FIGURE.
AND I THINK IT GOES UNDER THE
CA OF. FOR HEALTH SO ON IF YOU
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
HOMELESS I THINK IN IN MEDICAID
IN YOUR SEEN THIS NATIONALLY
GROWING YOU SAW THIS IN THE- IN
THE WHOLE PERSON CARE- AND HELP
HOMES PROGRAMS THE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN RUNNING FOR QUITE SOME
TIME IS THAT. ONCE YOU GET
SOMEONE HOUSE THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FOCUS ON
THEIR HEALTH BECAUSE OF THEIR
HOMELESS- AND HAVE NO HOUSING
IT'S VERY HARD FOR THEM TO
FOCUS ON THEIR DIABETES OR
ACTUALLY GETTING INTO TREATMENT
AND SO WE DO CONSIDER. ON WE DO
SUPPORT THE HOUSING FIRST A
PROMISE IN MAKING SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS GET HOUSE ON A WE
DO CONSIDER AT THAT OVER TIME
BY INVESTING IN THINGS LIKE
THE- NAVIGATION SERVICES THE
DEPOSITS. ON THE SUSTAINING
LIAISON SERVICES THAT OVER TIME
THE ACTUAL WILL BEND THE COST
CURVE IN REGARDS TO IMPROVING
PEOPLE'S HEALTH GETTING I'M OUT
OF THE EMERGENCY ROOM OR THE
INPATIENT STAY. ON WHICH
ULTIMATELY PAYS FOR BUT THIRD
CALL THIS IN LIEU OF SERVICES
IT'S NOT THE BEST NAME BUT IT
IS- BUT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CALLS. SO I JUST KEPT LINK I DO
A THAT IF WE CAN DO THAT IT'S A
DEAL BUT I THINK THE IDEA OF
ASKING MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS.
I'M STILL A LITTLE HAZY ON HOW
THAT THEY WOULD ACTUALLY. HAVE
TO WRITE A PRESCRIPTION IT
WOULD BE THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
WHETHER. MANAGED BETTER IS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION OR
POSITION SWEAT AND FIGHT
SOMEONE WHO. POTENTIALLY IT.
DOESN'T HAVE HOUSING RIGHT. THE
TO WOULD BE COOL THING
INFORMATION BE ABLE TO SAY THAT
THEY WOULD A GOOD. FIT WE HAVE
I'M NAVIGATORS AND OR ENHANCE
YOUR MAJOR PROVIDERS WHO WOULD
BE IDENTIFIED IN INDIVIDUALS.
BASED REFERRALS FROM WRITERS.
AND OR FROM DUE TO GO OUT TO
EACH BASS KIND OF OUR SERVICE
THEY WOULD I. SO AND SEE A
THEY'RE A GOOD. FOR HOW THINGS
SEE IF ARE DUE TO BE. SOMETHING
THAT TAKE A REALLY LONG TIME.
I'M IT TAKES TIME TO BUILD
TRUST SOMEBODY. SO IT'S A SIR
THE DOCTOR HOUSE RIGHT A
CAPTION HOUSE THOUGH I. THINK
IT'S THE AROUND THE IDEA OF.
LINKAGE BETWEEN. HOUSE. SAYS TO
LOOK AT THE SOCIAL SERVICES
THAT ARE IMPACTING SOMEONE'S
ABILITY TO BE WELL. OR TO
IMPROVE THEIR HEALTH AND MAKING
SURE THAT THOSE ARE AVAILABLE
ON FOR INDIVIDUALS THROUGH OUR
MEDI CAL PROGRAM THAT MAKES
SENSE OKAY THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER I JUST
WANT OTHER FULL QUESTION WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THIS WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP- THESE
FOLKS HOW YOU CAN GET THIS
INFORMATION OUT TO ALL OF THE
POPULATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
HELD I MEAN UNFORTUNATELY- THIS
IS THE FIRST TASK IN WHAT IS
YOUR PLAN TO BASICALLY MARKET
THIS YEAH SO THE DEPARTMENT-
STARTED ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS-
AT THE END OF OCTOBER WE
RELEASED OUR MASSIVE MEDI CAL
HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA FOR ALL WE
ARE- WRAPPING UP NEXT WEEK FOR
MONTHS OF INTENSIVE WORK GROUP
SESSIONS WHERE WE HAVE BEEN I'M
GETTING A LOT OF FEEDBACK ON
WHAT'S WORKING WHAT'S NOT WHAT
ARE THE THINGS WE NEED TO
CONSIDER WITH THIS PROPOSAL-
AND THEN WE WILL ARE WE ARE
KIND OF PIVOTING. ON AFTER THAT
TO KIND OF THINK THROUGH
IMPLEMENTATION BECAUSE AS YOU
MENTIONED THERE IT IS A VERY
AGGRESSIVE GOAL IN REGARDS TO
ROLLING OUT A STATEWIDE ENHANCE
CARE MANAGEMENT BENEFIT BY
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
I'M SO CREATED WHAT WE'RE
CALLING TOOL KITS- THAT WE WILL
BE ROLLING OUT WHERE IF
SOMEONE'S BEING FROM WHOLE
PERSON QUE ENHANCE CARE
MANAGEMENT AND OF SERVICES DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE HOW TO MANAGED
CARE PLANS WORK WITH PROVIDERS
HE'S I'M COST. DONE TRIMS THOSE
WORDS TO FOR SEVEN MOVING FROM
HEALTH ALL ON INTO THAT AND
WILL BE NOT DOING IS HAVING
MEETING THAT WOULD BE IN APRIL
AND MAY WE WOULD GO OUT IN CAN
BE MANAGED CARE PLAN CAO THE
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AS RIDERS WHO
WOULD BE CAN TO DO THIS WORK A
INFORM THEM OF THE BAY IN FORM
OF A THE AFFECT OF THIS AND DE
THAN COMP CASE MAY THAT DO
TODAY I AND THEN WE WOULD.
IDENTIFYING THOSE REGIONAL
WORKS INDIVIDUAL AREAS FOR
CALLING THEM TEAM ANNOUNCED
TERM WHERE WOULD I DO THIS
PROJECT ACCOUNTING IS HAVE
TROUBLE IS PART PIECE OF AND
RUNNING WE WOULD SEND IT STRIKE
MEANS TO THAT AREA TO HELP A
FIGURE OUT WHAT SHE OUR MEDIC
THOSE AND MAKE SURE FOR SUCCESS
HAPPEN UP. NIGHT IT WILL HAVE.
ARE VERY COMMITTED BUT THAT IS
SUCCESSFUL GIVEN THAT THE
POPULATIONS WERE TALKING ABOUT
OUR SOME OF OUR MOST BOND POP
TUNES. I THINK IN THAT VEIN IF
YOU THINK ABOUTTHE OFFER THAT
EACH ONE OF THE HAS LET'S. HAVE
THROUGH OUR MAIL. OF BEING ABLE
TO REACH OUT TOWARDS. BASE
PARTNERING WITH THE AGE IN
MAKING THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
HAVE AND FOR. ON A ON A GLOBAL
YOU KNOW KIND OF YOU TALK ABOUT
HOW TWENTY LEGISLATORS. BEING
ABLE TO PUT THEIR MAIL OUT TO.
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THE POPULAR.
HILL IS ANOTHER OFFER. A GOING
FOR. SIR WE OR SOMETHING WE
SHOULD. TALK ABOUT. SO MATHIS.
WE KEEP HEARING. HOUSING FOR
BUT- WHY ABOUT TREATMENT TRENDS
AS I MEAN MY CAN THAT I'VE OVER
AND OVER AND OVER IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS BOTH BACK HOME WITH
PROFESSIONALS AND THE LAST SIX
YEARS HERE IN THE CAPITAL WE
TALK ABOUT HOUSING FIRST LET'S
GET THE MENTAL HOME SO THEN WE
CAN ADDRESS THE REST OF THE
HEALTH. BUT FOR THOSE THAT ARE
ON THE STREETS WOULDN'T YOU
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO GET THEM
THE TREATMENT AND TRANSITION
THEM. FROM SOME KIND OF A
TREATMENT FACILITY WHERE THEY
WERE THEY'RE GETTING THE HELP
<c.red>N THE WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT</c>
ARE NEEDED. BEFORE WE PUT ON A
NEW HOME. SO UNDER I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE NOT YEAH THIS SCENE
THAT IT'S FAIR THERE ARE-
MULTIPLE LAYERS TO THE IN LIEU
OF SERVICES PACKAGE- AND WE'VE
BEEN TOLD WE NEED TO COME UP
WITH THE DIFFERENT NAMES OF
WORKING ON THAT- BUT
ESSENTIALLY WE DO HAVE OPTIONS
LIKE. RECUPERATIVE CARE WHERE
YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO IS IN AN
INPATIENT SETTING FOR EXAMPLE-
AND INSTEAD OF THEM SITTING IN
LINGERING IN AN INPATIENT
SETTING FOR A LONG TIME OR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY WHERE
NO ONE'S GONNA JUST CHARGE THEM
TO THE STREET GIVEN THEIR
POTENTIAL. EITHER MEDICAL OR
PHYSICAL OR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITION ON THAT THEY COULD
TRANSITION TO A RECRUITER OF
CARE. BED WHICH IS A TEMPORARY
SETTING- IT DOES HAVE A THE
FEDERAL MAXIMUM THE NINETY DAYS
IN THAT PARTICULAR BUT IT IS A
TEMPORARY SETTING TO A BE ABLE
TO IDENTIFY. ON GET IN IT HAS
CARE MANAGER. MANAGER THERE TO
WORK WITH THEM OR TO IDENTIFY
WHAT TREATMENTSERVICES THEY
ARE ARE NOT RECEIVING TO GET
THEM LINKED UP WITH. A TEN
BEHAVIOR ALL COUNTY SERVICES
THEY'RE NOT ALREADY THERE OR
CAN BE IN THEM IN THOSE
SERVICES SO THERE IS
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN OUR
PACKAGE THAT DOES LOOK AT STEP
DOWN FACILITY SERVICES NOT JUST
THE NAVIGATION OR THE LONGER
TERM PIECES. I'M TO MAKE SURE
WE CAN CAPTURE PEOPLE WOULD
ALLOW PEOPLE BEING RELEASED
FROM INCARCERATION ALSO ACCESS
THOSE SERVICES FOR INSTITUTIONS
OF SOMEONE WHO IS EVEN ACCESS
THE- I'M IN IT TO SHOW LEVEL OF
CARE BEING. CHARGED ON THEY
WERE HOME PRIOR THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO ALSO ASK THE TYPES OF.
THE NICE ABOUT RETRIBUTIVE OR
WHAT WE CALL HOSPITALIZATION
SERVICES WHICH IS A THERE I'M
AT ALLOWED YOU TO HAVE IT. SO
BY YOU LOOKING FOR OP. GETTING
THEM TREATMENT AND THEN LINKED
UP WITH THOSE PIECES SO WE DO
THINK TREAT IS VERY IMPORTANT
AS WELL AND WE DO HAVE KIND OF
TEMPORARY AND LONGER TERM
SOLUTIONS THAT CAN'T USE
STATEWIDE. OF I'VE BEEN. WE HAD
A PAUL. PAUL ON THIS BY HOME.
IN DECEMBER. WE EVERYBODY
WALKED AWAY STARTED CALLING AT
THE- T. BE. TREE TREATMENTFOR.
THE ME THAT EDGE. P. OF THEN
THEY HAVE SOME. TO GO TO THE
WORD. BUT WE DEL. WE DON'T HEAR
ENOUGH ABOUT IT A AND IF WE GET
HYPER FOCUSED ON THE HOUSING.
SIDE OF THINGS BUT- WE NEED
SOMEWHERE FOR THE FOLKS TO GO
THAT'S NOT A JAIL. TO RECEIVE
THAT TREATMENT- WHETHER IT'S
THAT NINETY DAY HOLD AND THEN
THEY AN OPTION TO GO TO
SOMEWHERE ELSE. TO FINALIZE
TREATMENT IN START EDUCATION
AND IN THOSE OTHER THINGS THAT
WILL SET THEM UP FOR SUCCESS
WHAT WHETHER IT'S- YOU KNOW IT
ADULT SCHOOL. IN TWO. B. L. A
CAREER PATH IN THE TRADES OR
COLLEGE OR WHATEVER. WHERE THEY
CAN ACTUALLY START MOVING
FORWARD BECAUSE- WITHOUT THAT
IT'S THE AGAIN WE CAN THE
FEDERAL HOUSE ADAMANT THROW
MONEY AT HOME BUT INTEL WE
ACTUALLY GET THAT WHOLE
WRAPAROUND WHERE. OKAY YOU'RE
YOU'RE SOMEWHERE SAFE. LET'S
GET YOU CLEANED UP LET'S GET
YOU CLEANED IF THAT'S THE ISSUE
LET'S FIND OUT WHAT THE OTHER
UNDERLYING YOU KNOW FILL THAT
ONION BACK AND FIND OUT WHAT
THE OTHER UNDERLINING ISSUES
ALL OUR- BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
SEEING A LOT OF IN AGAIN THIS
IS BASED ON THE POLICY BECAUSE
I HAD. BRING EVERYBODY IN. YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU BRING IN YOU TALK
TO THE SHERIFF YOU TALK TO THE
DA'S YOU TALK TO. THE SOCIAL
WORKERS YOU TALK TO YOUR
DEPARTMENT HUMAN HEALTH AND YOU
HAVE EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE.
IT'S REALLY YOU START TELLING
THAT BACK AND IT'S GONE OKAY
WILL OKAY WE GOTTA GET HIM
CLEANED UP. IN OFF THEIR DRUG
HABITS. BUT THEN THERE'S THE
UNDERLINING MENTAL HEALTH. THAT
LEFT OVER BECAUSE THEY GOT ON.
THE DRUGS WHICH GETS IN THE
WHOLE OPIOID BOMB
METHAMPHETAMINE MEDIAN EPIDEMIC.
YOU KNOW AND THAT'S A PUBLIC
SAFETY SIDE THAT WE HAVE TO.
INTO THIS IN A WORK WITH THEM
AS PARTNERS ON ON WHAT THIS
LOOKS LIKE- THE ASSEMBLY AROUND
THOSE PENSION YOU KNOW IT'S-
YOU ALMOST NEED TO ENSURE THAT.
WHEN AND I'VE BEEN ON THE
POLICE RIDE ALONGS. WHEN YOU GO
OUT THERE THE TRIAGE IS
HAPPENING ON THE ROAD SIDE BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR IN THE BACK
OF AN AMBULANCE TAKING THEM TO
ANY ARE. AND THAT'S NOT WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITH THAT THE
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE THAT OUT
RIGHT THERE AT THE START.
BECAUSE THE I MEAN I'VE I'VE
BEEN ON THE CALLS AND IT'S YOUR
DRIVING AROUND WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND- THERE'S
SOMEBODY WHO'S PASSED OUT THAT
YOU KNOW. ROLLED INTO THE
MIDDLE OF THE ROADER THEIR LEGS
ARE STICKING OUT SO THEY
STOPPED TO CHECK AND SEE IF
THEY'RE OKAY. BUT YOU KNOW YOU
FIND OUT OKAY WELL THIS GUY'S
GOT DRUGS ON THEY'VE GOT OTHER
STUFF ON ON. BUT THERE'S
NOTHING THEY CAN DO. RIGHT NOW
BASED ON WITH THE WAY THINGS
ARE SO WE'VE GOT IT THAT'S THAT
STARTING PIECE. THAT WERE
MISSING A PHILIP WERE WORKING
BACKWARDS BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S WE
KEEP HEARING OUSING FIRST
HOUSING FIRST HOUSING FIRST.
BUT UNLESS WE START GETTING
THAT TREATMENT IN THAT TRIAGE
PIECE DOWN. NONE OF THE OTHER
STUFF CAN ACCOUNT. THIS IS THE
WICKS YEAH I JUST I JUST ECHO
THAT- INTEREST THAT HOUSING
FIRST AS I'VE OFTEN HEARD THAT
DOES NOT MEAN HOUSING ONLY- AND
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
INTENT THE APPROACH THAT WE
INTEND THAT WHILE HOUSING IS
NECESSARY TO- PROVIDE STABILITY
IN ALLOW SOMEONE TO ENGAGE IN
THOSE SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND
THE TREATMENT THAT HEY MAY
NEED IF THOSE ARE THEIR NEEDS
OUR INTENTION IS FOR THE FUNDS
HE HEARD THE- TO SERVICE. OTHER
PLACE. TO ALLOW HOUSING AND
SUPPORTS. AND IT'S NOT A US FOR
ANY FINAL QUESTIONS MAY HAVE
THE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB WITH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR THAT UP SO MEMBER. AND
PART OF THAT THE HOUSING FIRST-
ALSO BRINGS IN WRAPAROUND
SERVICES- TO THE INDIVIDUAL SO
WHEN THE INITIAL INTAKE IS
DONE. YOU'LL BE ABLE TO HAVE
THOSE SERVICES THERE TO HELP
GET THE PERSON READY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE HOUSING. SO
WRAPAROUND SERVICES PLAYS A BIG
PART IN THAT AND I THANK YOU
FOR SO MUCH ATTENTION COME TO
THE TO A LOT OF THOSE-
TREATMENTS- THAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT IN YOUR
PRESENTATION. WE KNOW THAT.
ENABLE SOMEBODY BE. THEY HAVE
TO BE A TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING OFF OF. CERTAIN
ELEMENTS THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
THEIR LIVES TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING
INTO THAT HOUSE AND ULTIMATELY
MOVING ON THEIR LIVES- WE
TALKED ABOUT A PROJECT. DOWNEY
LOMA LINDA WELL WE TALKED ABOUT
WAS VETERANS THAT WERE OUT
THERE. YEAH BUT BEING ABLE TO
DURING THE INTAKE BEFORE THEY
GOT INTO THE HOUSE. FIND OUT
WHAT ISSUES THAT THEY WERE
ACTUALLY SEEN. WHAT WERE THEY
GOING THROUGH IF IT WAS ALCOHOL
IS A MOVE IT WAS DRUGS WAS
OTHER THINGS. YOU'RE ABLE TO
TREAT THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY WERE SUCCESSFUL IN MOVING
FORWARD. I THINK A LOT OF THE
APPROACHES THAT YOU'RE BRINGING
UP. DEALS WITH THAT THAT THAT.
THAT SORT OF THE PERSON TO BE
SUCCESSFUL- CERTAINLY WE CAN'T
JUST SAY WE'RE GONNA HOW'S YOUR
BODY. BECAUSE EVERYBODY WILL
SUCCESSFUL POINT. TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE RESIDENCE. CRY RESIN.
TREATMENTS LAW FIRM AS WELL AS
CONTINUE WITH A CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS SO THANK
YOU FOR PRESENT. AND GIVING US
AT INTO THE- SIR. I'M TO. IN
THE HOUSING ELEMENT OF HOUSING
FOR. THIS BILL QUICK QUEST FOR
YOU BELT THING BUT- EARLY
ACTION WHICH WAS MEAN WE THE
HAS MISTREATMENT THAT WITH A-
OUT WE HAVE PROVIDED YOU SOME
DRAFT TRAILER BILL. IN I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED OR
FEEDBACK AND THOSE. I ASSUME A
BE ON GO WITH FIRST TO THAT LAY
THE GOVERNOR'S SCHOOL IS FOR
THE LANGUAGE TO BE AND- IN THE-
WEEKS AND THEN. THAT WE WILL BE
PER. AGAIN THE OUR FEET TO. BE
DRAFTED AND READY TO GO AND FOR
THE FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT-
AS SOON AS THE BUT IT IS AN
ACTIVE. FOR YOU. ALL HOW I'M
IT'S POSTED ON THE OF FINE WEB
IT'S OF. I'M ALL IN THE SPAN
JUST BY SAYING HOW I AM THAT
SOME OF BEST PRACTICES ROLLED
OUT TO ALL THE- A PERSON CARE
WAS NOT AVAILABLE DESPITE SOME
OF OUR BEST EFFORTS AND
COUNTIES MANY OF US REPRESENT
AS WELL AND SO- I'D PROBABLY
ECHO ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER'S
COMMENTS AS WELL IF I COULD FOR
THE NEED FOR. MORE INFORMATION
AND DETAILS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
APPROPRIATE. CAN MAKE AN
APPROPRIATE DECISION WHEN THE
TIME'S RIGHT SO- WITH THAT WE
WILL THANK THIS PANEL FOR
COMING FORWARD AND MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US IN. IF CAN START THE NEXT
PANELS WITH THE SOME. SANTIAGO
AND WHERE. AND POTENTIALLY. AND
THEN. ALL HAVE LUIS QUE
MICHELLE CABRERA AND JAMES CAAN
SAN SAID. AND PHIL ANSEL.
SORRY
FOR YOU WAITING SENATE MEMBERS
ON THE I THINK YOU MISSED
BELONGS TO PRESENT THIS
IMPORTANT OVER HERE PRESENT THE
DAY IS A EIGHT RE FOR TWO
DOLLARS IN ONGOING MONEY TACKLE
THIS ISSUE HOME I MEAN I DON'T
THINK THAT TO THE HAN THIS IS
OR THAT WERE CLOSED BY A
HUNDRED IS PA THAN. THIS NEXT
COUNTY IN THAT MEANS AND OF
WERE ON THE STREETS INCLUDING
CHILL AND WHEN WE TOOK A LOOK
AT THE CRISIS IN THE MAY OF IT
WE WILL THAT WE- A LOT THAN
THAT A STING FROM. WHILE THE
LEDGE BEEN PERSONAL YEARS ALRP
BEING FOUGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOR HE. THE TWO BILLION UP.
GOING ON ALLOCATION AND I THINK
THE ISTHE RIGHT TO DO IT WE
GOT A SIX BILL DOLLAR SIR. WITH
A LOOK AT THE NAY ADDED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BY. ABOUT
POINT OF 9% NOT EVEN 1% WHEN
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT JUST A CHEN
FUND ALL. WERE LOOK AT ABOUT
CLOSED POINT 3% I AM NOT THE
MODEST COMPARED KIND OF PROBLEM
THAT WE'RE NOT FOR. WAS AND THE
REASON WE'RE LOOKING FOR LONG
TERM PROPOSAL IS. WE AND I
THINK MOST OF MOST OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WOULD AGREE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PLAN TO. HOMELESS
WE HAVE TO AN YEAR BY YEAR
WE'VE UP WHAT WOULD A- CLOSED
UP. BUT REQUEST THAT BASIC SAYS
BILLION FIFTY FIVE PER GOES TO
CAN OF AND CAL 40% WOULD GO TO
THE CITIES AND 5% WOULD BE IT
WOULD GO TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
AND WE CAN GET IN THE DETAILS
AS THE COMMITTEE CHOOSES TO
ADDRESS- QUESTIONS TO US BUT I
DON'T KNOW HOW ELSE TO SAY WHEN
YOU HAVE CHILDREN LIVING ON THE
STREETS AND LITERALLY IT'S-
PEOPLE DIE ON THE STREETS.
EVERYDAY WE NEED THIS WE NEED
AS MANY OF TACKLE THIS ISSUE.
AND I'D LIKE TO HAND OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS ALTERNATIVE
PROPOSAL- FOR ASKING FOR TWO
BILLION DOLLARS TO DRESS
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS WHICH- TO BILLIONS A LOT
OF MONEY BUT FRANKLY. YOU KNOW
ITS- A DEBT OF WHAT I THINK WE
NEED TO DO. A WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN MY
DISTRICT IN PARTICULAR ABOUT A
47% INCREASE IN HOMELESSNESS IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS IN OAKLAND-
YOU KNOW OUR LOCAL OFFICIALS.
ARE CRAP. HOW TO ADDRESS THE
FUNDAMENTALLY YOU KNOW WE
URGENCY IN THE GOVERNOR SPEECH
THIS MORNING OR THE URGENCY
RIGHT WE'LL TALK TO. MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE. TO THIS ISSUE
THE VERY WE SEE IN LA BUT IT'S
NOT JUST BAY AREA ISSUE IT'S
NOT JUST IN A LOS ANGELES
ISSUE. IT'S IMPACTING ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND FOR SERIOUS ABOUT
SOLVING THE PROBLEM IF TO BE
SERIOUS ABOUT THE- THEIR
WILLING TO PUT INTO IT- YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN VERY WE HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN CALIFORNIA-
IN TERMS OF SPENDING KEEP. AND
HAVE MONEY- HAD ARE YOU KNOW
CAN BE CABIN SITES PROJECTS
UNDER WAY- WE'VE. SIX THIRTY.
YOU SHELTER. PLEA FOR. SAYING
I'M THE RESOURCE THAT WE CAN
PUT A THIS I. WILL GO A LONG
WAY YOU KNOW THE FIRST I DID
WHEN I WAS ELECT. AS I WON ON A
TOUR OF THE CAMPUS TO MY JUST.
THAT ALL OVER MY DESK. AND IT'S
HARD WRENCHING THE- THIS. OF
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK. THIS AND
WE HAVE TO. I IS LEADERS OF
THIS. PUTTING THOSE STORIES
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE MAKE
THESE PUBLIC POLICY DECISIONS.
AND PUTTING OUR OUR OUR MONEY
WHERE OUR MOUTH IS AND MAKING A
REAL SERIOUS COMMITMENT. TO
ENDING THIS CRISIS SO I'M
HONORED TO BE WORKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES HERE
MANY OTHERS WHO CARE ABOUT THIS.
DISGRUNTLED GOOD AFTERNOON A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND HAD CO
CHAIRS THANK YOU REVEREND ME MY
NAME IS PHIL AND SELLING THE
DIRECTOR OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HOMELESS INITIATIVE AND I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF AN
EXTRAORDINARY MOVEMENT THAT HAS
SWEPT ACROSS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS TO
PREVENT AND COMBAT HOMELESSNESS.
SINCE LOS ANGELES COUNTY VOTERS
APPROVED A DEDICATED SALES TAX
OF ONE QUARTER PERCENT IN MARCH
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN. WITH THAT
SALES TAX REVENUE ALONE WE HAVE
HELPED NEARLY THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND FAMILY MEMBERS
INDIVIDUALS MOVE INTO AN ARM
HAS IN AN EVER HELD NEARLY
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FAMILY
MEMBERS AND INDIVIDUALS TO MOVE
INTO PERMANENT HOUSING. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN COMPARED TO
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN ARE
HOMELESS SERVICES SYSTEM HELPED
DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF FAMILY
MEMBERS INDIVIDUALS MOVING TO
PERMIT HOUSING. BUT I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF OUR BRAND
I'M PRESIDENT A COALITION IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL FOR TWO
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
BECAUSE DESPITE OUR HISTORIC
RABBIT LEVEL OF LOCAL REVENUES
AND OUR HISTORIC EFFORTS AND
OUR HISTORIC LEVEL OF SUCCESS
IN MOVING PEOPLE FROM
HOMELESSNESS INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING WHAT WE ARE ABLE TO DO
LOCALLY IS INSUFFICIENT. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE PEOPLE PER DAY
EXITED HOMELESSNESS INTER
PERMANENT HOUSING LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BUT ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
PEOPLE PER DAY. ELLEN
HOMELESSNESS ACCOUNTING FOR
TWELVE FOR AND- IN OUR HOME IS.
WE NEED YOUR ASSISTANCE IN
PROVIDING FINDING. TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WE
CAN HELP ACCESS HOMELESSNESS
WITH THE PRIMARY BARRIER TO
DOING THAT IS FUNDING FOR
RENTAL SUBSIDIES AND AT THE
SAME TIME WE NEED YOUR
ASSISTANCE WITH POLICY CHANGES.
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
BECOMING HOMELESS. THE KEY
ELEMENTS AS THE PROPOSAL THAT
WAS PUT TOGETHER BY THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES. THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY OUR
PRIMARY CONTINUUM OF CARE. AND
UNITED WAY OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES. IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND HOUSING CALIFORNIA
ARE. TWO BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
AN ON GOING STATE FINDING. IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE FROM THE
GENERAL FIND ANY SORTS WILL DO
AS LONG AS IT'S TWO BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND I'M GOING
FUNDING. SECONDLY AS SOMEONE
SENT YOU A GOOD DESCRIBE
RECOMMENDED 55% OF THAT FINING
GO JOINTLY TO CONTAIN HYMNS OF
CARE AND COUNTIES AND FORTY
PERCENT. TO THE THIRTEEN AT BIG
CITIES THERE PREVIOUSLY
RECEIVED KEEPING OUT FUNDING
AND THAT THAT FUNDING BE
DISTRIBUTED ON A FORMULA BASIS.
I'M DEPENDENT ON TWO FACTORS
POINT 70% BASED ON POINT IN
TIME COUNT 30% BASED. ON THE
NUMBER OF RUNNERS WERE
SEVERELY. RENT BURDENED. THE
FINAL ELEMENT ARE PER THAT
DEMAND. IS IN REAL THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS THAT WE
DO NOT INCLUDE. SOLVING THE
BOARDING CARE CRISIS WITHIN
THIS PROPOSAL. WARNING CARES-
ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND
CERTAINLY TO THE EXTENT THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS NEEDS THE LEVEL OF
CARE BORN CARE CAN PROVIDE THAT
CAN PROVIDE A BORN CARE CAN BE
A PERMANENT HOUSING SOLUTION.
BUT FOR THE SYSTEMIC PROBLEM AS
IN ADEQUATE RATE REIMBURSEMENT
WHICH IS THREATENING MASSIVE
CLOSURES ARE BORN CARE
FACILITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED A DEDICATED SOLUTION TO
THAT AND ARE COUNTY SUPPORTS
THE PROPOSAL BY THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR ON A ONE TIME BASIS TO
STAUNCH THE BLEEDING. AND ALLOW
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN
ONGOING PLAN TO SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WEEK OF LOUIS CALDERON DOCUMENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. I'M LOU
GOVERNOR ON THE ACT IN THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE GET COULD.
APOLOGIA HOW LOST MY BOY
YESTERDAY. CENTER THIS GARDEN
OF. OUR FIFTY NINE UP WITH AND
CRISIS. LAW SUPPORTING CARE
LAST YEAR SAN FRANCISCO LOS A
FOR YOU ABLE TO MEET MY CLOSER
JUST AS I. PERFECT. TWO FIFTY
SIX FIFTY SIX HOMES THAT'S A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR CLANS
THE LOST THEIR THEM THE THEIR
HOMES- WITH HIGH COST OF LIVING
AND HIGH- ACOSTA HOUSING-
OPERATORS ARE SIMPLY NOT ABLE
TO MAINTAIN AND- PAY FOR THE
BILLS ON A DAILY BASIS- THEY
ARE NOT ABLE TO PAY THAT WITH
THE- AT THE SIDE. PAYMENT
COMPONENT AND THE PATCHES OR
THE SUBSIDY THAT WE THAT WE
THAT COUNTIES HAVE PROVIDING-
THIS SIMPLY IS NOT ENOUGH TO
COMPETE ON TO HIGHER FOR
WORKERS LAST YEAR WHEN THE
MINIMUM WAGE WENT UP. WE
LITERALLY HER FROM DESPERATE-
OPERATOR SAYING THAT WE CANNOT
AFFORD OR EVEN COMPETE WITH
THEM OR FIND. WORKERS TO WORK
FOR OUR FACILITY THE MINIMUM
WAGE WHEN THEY CAN GET MORE
WORKING FOR THE TECH COMANY
DOWN THE STREET. TRANSPORTING
THEIR SERVICES AND OTHER THINGS
LIKE THAT- I'M FOURTEEN MANY OF
THIS SOME OF THESE FACILITIES
HAVE OPT OUT. I ISSUE EVICTION
NOTICE TO APPLY. AND PLAYS A-
FOR SALE. BY AUGUST LAST YEAR
WE HAVE SEVEN FACILITIES- IN
EARLY INTENT TO CLOCK IN TO
CLOSE THAT WAS WAS RESULTING IN
SEVENTY ONE CLIENTS BEING THIS
PLACE. WE WERE ONLY ABLE TO FOR
THE STATE'S AFFORDABLE SO TEETH.
SINCE DO THIS THIS PLACE
CLIENTS ARE THE HEART OF OUR
STORY ACTUALLY THEY ARE THE
PENDANT ADULTS AND SENIORS WITH
MENTAL HEALT. AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE THEM HISTORIES AND IN AND
THE STRUCTURE SENDING THINGS
WHERE THEY TO SEE THE BEST. BY
THE TIME I DID THEY NEED THIS-
BOARDING KERRY STRUCTURE SIR
SETTINGS. THEY HAVE BUT LIKELY
HAD MULTIPLE HOSPITALIZATIONS
EXTENDED HOMELESSNESS. THEN THE
HOMELESSNESS INCARCERATIONS-
AND SUFFERS SOME OTHER DRAMATIC
MEDICAL. CONDITION LIKE A
STROKE. RENAL FAILURE OF OAK OR
DIABETES. THEY ARE UP OF COLOR
MAJORITY WITH LANGUAGE PLEASE
AN INCREASINGLY IN THE OLDER
POPULATION. THEY'RE NO LONGER
ABLE TO MANAGE THEIR DAILY
ACTIVITIES. THERE NEED
ASSISTANCE WITH MANAGING THEIR
MONEY AND THEIR MEDICATIONS
THEY ARE NEED A BOARDING CARE
TO MAINTAIN THEIR- INSTABILITY
AND BE ABLE TO GRADE A HOME
LIKE ENVIRONMENT FOR THEM.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN. THEY
RECEIVE IT M. WITH THE CLIENTS
RECEIVE THIS ADDICTION NOTICE
MANY OF THEM BECAUSE OF THE
PSYCHIATRIC A KIND OF
IMPAIRMENT OF THE COMPENSATED
ENDED UP IN THE STREETS BACK IN
THE HOSPITAL- AND WE SAW THAT
IN THIS LAST ROUND OF CLOSURE
LAST YEAR WE LOST- ARE NOW THE
ONLY PERSON THAT DECIDED TO
LEAVE OR WITH BECAUSE OF THE
CAR LIVING PAYMENT WAITING FOR
A BET TO UP THE TO FIND IN THE
IN THE COUNTY WE WERE PLANNING
TO MOVE ATTY COUNTING STE G.
THIS PERSON DID NOT WANT TO
MOVE AT A COUNTY. SHE LEFT THE
FACILITY I WAS FONG LATER IN
THE STREET SHE HAD TALKED TO A
SYSTEM OF CAVES SHELTERS BUT WE
FIND ON THE STREET BUT HER
BROUGHT HER BACK TO THE
HOSPITAL FOR A LONG STAY THERE
IN FACT THESE PLAYS IN THE FILL
IN THE HOME INFECTED CISCO. BUT
FAILING US THE FAILURE OF US
TO. DO SUPPORT THEIR HOMES
BOARDING. HAS BEEN A FAILURE IN
THE SYSTEM OF CARE PUT TO GET
ALL ALL TOGETHER. AND THIS IS
THE LAST- ISSUE THAT THE WITH
THE CLOSURE OF THE VOTING
CARES- THERE'S A RIPPLE EFFECT
ON OUR SYSTEM OF CARE- OUR
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
CLIENTS FROM A HIGHER LEVEL I
STRUCTURE MORE RESTRICTIVE AND
MORE COSTLY LEVELS OF CARE TO A
MORE CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE LIZ
RESTRICTOR AFFECTED SUPPORT
SERVICES IT'S IT GOES AWAY- WE
WHEN WE DO NOT HARBORING CARES-
IT MEANS THAT PATIENTS. WAITING
EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME IN
ACUTE BEDS HOSPITAL TO STAY
THERE LONGER IN MEANS CLIENTS
CANNOT STEP DOWN FROM LOCK LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES WHEN
THEY'RE READY ANY MEANS THAT-
CLIENTS COMPLETING RESIDENTIAL
DO WILL. DIAGNOSE TREATMENT OR
ARMS DON'T HAVE A BOARDING CARE
ABED TO CONTINUE I MAINTAINED
IT NEARLY GETTING STABILITY.
THAT'S SIMPLY THE SYSTEM OF
CARE THE SPECTER NEEDS TO BE
THERE AND WE LOSE THAT ABILITY-
COUNTY HOSPITALS AND A
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PARTNERS
ARE PHASE WITH MAKING VERY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS OF THESE
CHARGES CLIENTS FROM ACUTE
BEDS. TO OUR SHELTER SYSTEM
FROM TREATMENT BEDS TO EMERGES
DEVASTATION ROOMS OR SIMPLY TO
THE STREETS. BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO PLAY
THEM IN A STABLE SITUATION. I
LIKE A BOY CARE SUPPORT HOUSING.
I'M PART OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT TO INVEST IN
A ONE TIME FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR INFUSION OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO TRY TO STOP THE
BLEEDING OF CLOTHING OF ALL
THESE A BOARDING CARES WE HAVE
TO STOP THAT THAT LEGALLY
CANNOT CONTINUE EVERY SINGLE
YEAR LOSING THAT MANY PERMALINK
BETS WITH NO LONGER BE ABLE TO
REPLACE THOSE BETS. THE COST OF
HOUSING BY IN THAT HOME THE
COST THAT FAMILY MEMBER ALL
THAT THAT ENTITY SOMETIME AGO
ANONYMOUS ACOSTA MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TODAY CLEAN UP SOME OF
THE BIT REGULATORY BARRIERS AND
FINALLY CREATING- A COUNTIES
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THEM.
AT THE STATE DESPITE LONG TERM
CARE SOLUTIONS TO BUILD MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND CONTINUING OF
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
OPTIONS FOR HOMELESS AND
DISABLED INDIVIDUALS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
CURATE FOR LONG TERM SOLUTIONS
FOR THE FOR THIS POPULATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
MICHELLE. HI GOOD AFTER CHAIRED
MEMBERS MICHELLE COVERED IT UP
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE COUNTY SAFETY
NET SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA I'M HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ACCESS TO HOUSING
SERVICES FUND FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM. AND
FIRST MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR ITS
COMMITMENT TO TWO ISSUES THAT
LOOMS LARGEST FOR CALIFORNIANS
ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN GENERAL. THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS TAKEN
UNPARALLELED LEADERSHIP ON
THESE ISSUES REFLECTED IN
TODAY'S STATE OF THE STATE
WHICH FOCUSED LARGELY ON THE
NEED FOR THE STATE TO END
HOMELESSNESS THROUGH AGGRESSIVE
FOCUSED AND BOOSTING HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. AND SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUAL. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
LEVEL SET AN UNDER SCORE AT THE
BEGINNING HERE THAT- ACCORDING
TO OUR HAD STATISTICS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT SERIOUSLY
MENTALLY ILL OR LIVING WITH THE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER-
ACCORDING TO HIDE DATA THREE
FOURTHS. DO NOT HAVE A SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS OR S. U. D. WHAT
IT DOES SUGGEST IS THAT
INDIVIDUALS FACING HOMELESSNESS
IN CALIFORNIA. ARE VERY LOW
INCOME AND THE DATA ALSO TELLS
US THAT THEY ARE OLDER ADULTS
SO HALF OF ALL OF OUR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS ARE OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY AND OF THOSE HALF OF THEM
ENTERED HOMELESSNESS FOR THE
VERY FIRST TIME. AFTER THE AGE
OF FIFTY- WHAT'S MOST
CONCERNING IS THAT THE
RESEARCHERS FIND WITH THIS AGE.
IT IS THE SEVENTY. FROM A
HEALTH STATUS PERSPECTIVE
THERE- BODIES. LOOK FEEL OUR
AND OUR EXPERIENCE THAT LIKE
THAT OF A SEVENTY FIVE OR
EIGHTY YEAR OLD NOT A FIFTY
YEAR OLD AND SO THE MORE TIME
THAT SPENT ON THE STREETS THE
MORE LIKELY THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE. BOTH TO DEVELOP A SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS OR OME
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITION OR
TO END UP IN NEED OF VERY
EXPENSIVE- HIGH COST CARE OF
LIKE THAT KIND THAT LEWIS
DESCRIBED IN HIS PROPOSAL- ARE
CALIFORNIA CRISIS IS ALSO
MARKED BY STRUCTURAL RACISM
AFFECTS. AFRICAN AMERICANS
INEFFICIENTLY OVERREPRESENTED
AMONG INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WHILE THERE ARE ONLY 6%
OF OUR STATE POPULATION. ARE UP
30% OF INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND THOSE
PROPORTIONS ARE HIGHER IN LA.
AND THIS DISPARITY MAPS ALMOST
EXACTLY TO THEIR OPEN OVER
REPRESENTATION IN OUR JAILS AND
PRISONS WHICH I THINK IS
NOTEWORTHY AND THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE X.
INSTINCT RESTORATION AT ONE
POINT IN THEIR LIVES. ARE AT
MUCH HIGHER RISK OF IT.
UNDERSTANDING ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL FOR SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WHILE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CLIENTS ARE CERTAINLY NOT THE
MAJORITY THEY ARE AMONG THE
HIGHEST NEEDS AND HIGHEST COST
SUBPOPULATIONS. AND OF POP UP
POLICY MAKERS WANT TO DO MORE
TO PREVENT OLDER ADULTS AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND OTHER LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS IN THE FIRST
PLACE. THESE GROUPS CAN OVER
TIME AND THROUGH THIS TRAUMA-
BECOME OUR CLIENTS AND THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE WANT FOR THEM- SO
WITH RESPECT TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CLIENTS-
LIVING ON THE STREETS YES 17%
HAVE A SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE. THAT ALCOHOLIC CHRONIC
ALCOHOLISM ARE BIG FACTORS
AMONG INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN ADDITION TO
OTHER- DRUG USE AND A SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS IS THE GROUP OF
CLIENTS THAT WE WORK WITH
PRIMARILY. OUR OUTREACH WORKERS
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH STAFF
WILL SPEND MONTHS EVEN YEARS
WORKING TO BUILD TRUST WITH
PEERS AND OUTREACH WORKERS
THESE ARE A SOCIAL WORKERS
CLINICIANS INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCED IN. ENGAGING IN
WORKING WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE BOTH SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL
AND EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
SO MUCH OF THIS WORK IS
ACTUALLY FUNDED THROUGH PROP
SIX FEET SIXTY THREE THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT. AND WHEN
WE ENGAGE OUR CLIENTS WE BRING
THEM INTO A PROP SIXTY THREE
FUNDED WHATEVER IT TAKES
APPROACH THIS IS HIGH TOUCH
CASE MANAGEMENT. LITERALLY
ANYTHING OUR CLIENTS NEED TO
GET THEM WHILE AND UP ON THEIR
FEET INCLUDING- PROVIDING THEM
WITH HOUSING GETTING THEM A
GOVERNMENT ID- ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING THAT'S NEEDED. THESE
MODELS ARE EVIDENCE BASED AND
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN PROVEN
TO SAVE THE STATE. ARE HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS IN OF WAITED
HOSPITALIZATIONS IN JAIL COSTS
THEY ARE EXTREMELY VULNERABLE
IN TERMS OF THEIR PHYSICAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS AND DO
NEED TO. TRANSITION TO HOUSING-
THE GOAL FOR OUR CLIENTS IS
LONG TERM RECOVERY WHICH
INCLUDES POVIDING TREATMENT
BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES PROVIDING
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
RECOVERY HOUSING RIVER
WRAPAROUND SERVICES TENANTS
SUPPORT. BOARDING CARE PATCHES
THOSE THINGS AND THIS IS WHERE
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT HOW
COUNTIES HAVE INVESTED TO DATE
IN ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS I
WOULD SAY WE ARE NOT JUST THE
FRONT LINES IN MANY PARTS OF
THE STATE'S AND I'LL PUT LA AND
SAN FRANCISCO ASIDE BECAUSE-
OKAY INFANTS. HAVE GONE ABOVE
AND I'M BUT IN MANY PARTS OF
THE STATE. THAT COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM ARE
REALLY THE FRONT LINES IN THERE
SOME OF THE ONLY PEOPLE OUT IN
THE STREETS TRYING TO ENGAGE
THE BROADER ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS- THROUGH THE
FUNDING THAT WE GET THROUGH
PROP SIXTY THREE WE'VE
ESTIMATED THAT WE'RE- WE'RE IN
FOR ABOUT. HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION A U. IN SIX BRIEF THE
IS SPLIT. YOUR TO OUR
HOMELESSNESS WE ARE ALL
LEVERAGE MEANT SERVER AFTER THE
OF IN A TIONAL AND BILL DOLLARS
IN I'M- HOW FUNDING. AN IS
SERVICES BOTH VENTURE IN WELL
AS REMAIN OUT REACHED SU TO
NUTS IT'S EVERY AND BEING. WITH
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES SO IT'S
HAPPENING ALREADY TO DAY AND I
THINK A YOU KNOW I WANT TO SORT
OF LEAVE THIS GROUP WITH-
AGREEMENT WITH THE SENTIMENT
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBERS- SANTIAGO
AND WICKS ARE PRESENTING WHICH
IS WE'RE WE'RE DOING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT. WE NEED TO
DO MUCH MORE TO DEAL WITH THE
SCALE OF THE ISSUE AND REALLY
TO GET UPSTREAM OF SOMEONE
ENDING UP IN THAT. ONE FOURTH
SUBSET CHRONICALLY ILL
POPULATION- BECAUSE WE'VE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT HOW WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BUILD OUR WAY OUT
OF THIS WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SPEND OUR WAY OUT OF IT I
ACTUALLY TAKE ISSUE WITH AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SPEND OUR
WAY OUT OF IT. I THINK YOU KNOW
WE CAN TALK HAVE CONVERSATION
ABOUT REDIRECTING FUNDS
SHIFTING FRIENDS FROM THIS
PRIORITY TO THAT PRIORITY BUT
ULTIMATELY THERE IS MONEY THAT
IS PROVEN TO BE WELL SPENT THAT-IS ON THE GROUNDS TODAY. AND
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT NEED TO
DO MUCH MORE TO ADDRES THE
BROADER VOLUME UP THE ISSUE AND
I THINK THAT WHEN OUR FOLKS ARE
SOME OF THE ONLY PEOPLE OUT
THERE. THERE IS A BROADER GROUP
OF PEOPLE HAVE EXPERIENCED. WHO
ARE SUFFERING BECAUSE BEING
HOMELESS IS NOT FUN EXPERIENCE
IT'S HARD AND IT DOESN'T HAVE
AN IMPACT ON YOUR MENTAL. THAT
PERSON IS DEALING WITH THEM THE
WHOLE PROBLEMS THAT COME ALONG
WITH BEING A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR WITH BEING ASKED TO
LEAVE YOUR HOME BECAUSE YOU
CAME OUT AS- TRANSGENDER OR-
CLEAR. THOSE SORTS OF MENTAL
HEALTH EFFECTS DO NOT MEAN THAT
THAT PERSON IS SERIOUSLY
MENTALLY ILL IT DOES NOT MEAN
THAT THEY HAVE A PSYCHOTIC
CONDITION IT MEANS THAT THEY
ARE. SUFFERING HOWEVER AND SO
IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT FOR US
GIVEN THAT OUR FUNDING IS TIED
TO SIR. THE MOST OF. SO TO BE
OF A OR TO TRY TO FOR OTHER%
SALUTE. AND OTHERS SIMPLY TO
EXIST. WE THINK THAT THERE IS A
WAY TO DO THIS ON A COMP. LEVEL
WHAT DO WANT TO DO IS PICK WAS
A REAL IMPORTANT PREVENTION.
WHETHER IT'S RENTAL IS. OR
BUILDING NEW UNITS OR DOING
ANYTHING ON THE PREVENTION SIDE
BOOSTING THE SS I RATES AT
CENTER WE DON'T WANT TO PICK
THAT AGAINST WHAT WE NEED FOR
THE MOST TO Q. AND OF THE
SPECTRUM. SO ONE OF OUR
CAUTIONS WITH THE FLEXIBLE FUND
IS ALLOWING SOME OTHER ENTITY
THAT'S NOT REALLY SORT OF
GROUNDED IN THE NEEDS OF. OUR
SPECIFIC SUB POPULATION TO CALL
IT IN TERMS OF THE BOARDING
NEEDS IN OUR COMMUNITY. BECAUSE
I WANT TO COMPETE WITH THE
RENTAL SUBSIDIES RIGHT I MEAN
BOTH ARE REALLY IMPORTANT BOTH
ARE NECESSARY TO GETTING US OUT
OF HERE SO WE EITHER THINK A
DEDICATED POT OF FUNDING FOR
BORDER BOARDING CARE WITHIN THE
FLEXIBLE FUND. OR SOMETHING
ELSE TO THIS TO SORT OF LIFT
THEM LET US MAKE IT LARGER IS
APPROPRIATE I ALSO WANT TO.
THAT WE HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN TO FIVE AB INTO
WHICH THE TRIAL TO. OF WITH BY
THE- I'M IS SIR LINK BETWEEN
SAY SERVING PURSER. WITH A THE-
WITH MEANT IN. THIS HAVE SHOWN
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS AND IF WE
CAN INTERRUPT THOSE CYCLES WE
CAN HELP ADDRESS THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS OVER ALL.
IN ADDITION. FINALLY I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT- OVERALL IN
TERMS OF- WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOTS CAL AIM AT CETERA- THE
EXISTING WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOTS FOR THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ARE VARIED THE-
ADDRESS DIFFERENT. GROUPS OF
PEOPLE AND MANY OF THEM DID NOT
ACTUALLY DEAL WITH INDIVIDUALS
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. THEY
HAD INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY HAVE
HAD OTHER BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS BUT NOT OUR CLIENTS AND
SO WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT- THERE ARE SOME GAPS
WITH THE EXISTING WHOLE PERSON
CARE PILOTS THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- THE CAL IN REQUIRES
THE MANAGED CARE PLANS TO WORK
WITH THE SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL
AND INDIVIDUALS WITH SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS. THAT POLICY
REALLY NEEDS TO BE- MOVED AND
PROGRESSED TO REQUIRE
COORDINATION WITH THE SPECIALTY
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT IS WORKING
WITH THOSE PEOPLE TODAY BECAUSE
WE REALLY HAVE THE EXPERTISE
AND WE'RE ALSO BRIEF MASTERS AT
BREEDING OTHER FUNDING SOURCES
THAT MEDI CAL- DOES NOT HAVE
THE ABILITY TO SORT OF WORK
WITH- SO WE WOULD ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WORK WITH US IN
STRENGTHENING THE CAL AIM
PROPOSAL TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THOSE POPULATIONS ARE PROPERLY
ADDRESSED WITHIN THAT- AND
FINALLY- YOU KNOW IN THE LONG
WERE RUN GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE
OF OUR PUBLIC BEHAVIOR HOT
HEALTH SAFETY NET FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS AS THE GOVERNOR
SAID TODAY WE HAVE HISTORICALLY
UNDER INVESTED IN KING THE
COMMITTEE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM- I THOUGHT THAT WAS A
REALLY POWERFUL STATEMENT ON
HIS PART. IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE FAILURE WE NEED TO START
SOMEWHERE BUT ONGOING SUSTAIN
STRUCTURAL CHANGES WILL BE
NECESSARY MOVING FORWARD AND WE
SEEM CAP MISSILE AS THIS BUDGET
PROPOSALS HAS THE BEGINNING OF
THAT THANK YOU THANK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JAMES CAHN
WRITES IN AND I'M AN EMPLOYMENT
RESOURCE SPECIALIST FOR SOLANO
COUNTY AND I WORK IN THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM I'M ALSO A MEMBER
OF SEIU TEN TO ONE AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING FOR SOLANO COUNTY
FOR OVER TWENTY ONE YEARS I'VE
MADE THIS MY LIFE'S WORK AND
WHILE IT CAN BE EMOTIONALLY
TAXING AND THANKLESS WORK. I
LOVE WHAT I DO. I FEEL LIKE I'M
MAKING A REAL DIFFERENCE IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES. I INTERACT WITH
SINGLE MOTHERS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. AND ARE ONLY ONE
STROKE OF BAD LUCK AWAY FROM
LOSING IT ALL ENDING UP ON THE
STREETS. AND LATELY I INTERACT
MORE MORE WITH THOSE LIVING IN
CARS. MOVING THEIR CARS FROM
PARKING LOTS TO FREEWAY
UNDERPASSES EACH NIGHT TO AVOID
BEING TAGGED AS HOMELESS. JUST
TWO MONTHS AGO BEFORE THE
HOLIDAYS I WORKED WITH THE
FAMILY WHOSE MONTHLY CASH GRANT
COVERED THEIR MONTHLY RENT JUST
BARELY. BUT WHEN A NEW PROPERTY
OWNERSHIP GROUP BROUGHT THEIR
APARTMENT COMPLEX THEY WERE
SUBJECT TO RE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS. THAT REQUIRED THEIR
HOUSEHOLD INCOME TO EXCEED TWO
TO THREE TIMES THEIR MONTHLY
RENT. WHEN THEY COULD NOT MEET
THIS REQUIREMENT THE FAMILY WAS
EVICTED AND THEY CAME TO MY
OFFICE FOR HOMELESS ASSISTANCE.
THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE THAT I
WORRY FAMILY WAS HOUSE. THIS IS.
FAILED WHAT I REALLY TO SAY TO
YOU TODAY IS YOU HAVE A PUBLIC
SECTOR WORK FORCE OUT THERE
PUBLIC SERVANTS. WHO HAVE
DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO TRY TO
HELP THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
SOCIAL SERVICES WORKERS MENTAL
HEALTH WORKERS AND EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES WORKERS LIKE ME WHO
ARE IN A UNIQUE POSITION TO
DELIVER PUBLIC SAFETY NET
BENEFITS IN SUPPORT OF
SERVICES. TO THE HOMELESS SO
USE US. IF YOU REALLY WANT TO
TACKLE THE- THIS HEAD ON WE
NEED TO GET THOSE IN NEED.
ACCESS TO PROGRAMS THAT ONLY
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES WORK WAS
LIKE MYSELF CAN PROVIDE. WHEN
WE DO PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES
WERE ABLE TO CHANGE LIVESAND
WEREN'T ABLE TO PULL PEOPLE OUT
OF POVERTY THE PAIR. AND THEM
ON THE PATH TO SELF SUFFICIENCY
IT GIVES SOME SELF WORTH
INSTABILITY. WELL WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOGNITION THAT THIS CRISIS
MUST BE DEALT WITH IMMEDIATELY.
AND THAT IT WILL REQUIRE AN
INFUSION OF SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF SOME OF STATE GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
THAT THAT FUNDING IS FOR ONE
TIME DOLLARS. RATHER THAN AN
ONGOING EXPENDITURE AS WAS THE
FACT THAT THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT
INCLUDE A RELIANCE UPON OUR-
COUNTY PUBLIC SECTOR SOCIALS.
SAFETY NET. THEREFORE WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO. CONSIDER A
SUBSTANTIAL ONGOING ALLOCATION
THE STATE GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
PROVIDING AN OUT STATIONING OF
COUNTY MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS
AT LOCATIONS EASILY ACCESSIBLE
BY THE HOMELESS AND THE
HOMELESS IN SECURE. THE IDEA
THAT ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE
CAN GET QUALIFIED ONLY AT
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES COUNTY
OFFICES IS OUTDATED AND
UNREALISTIC. IT IS THE
AVAILABILITY OF PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT OFTEN MEANS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BEING ABLE
STAND ONCE HOME BECOMING
HOMELESS OR GETTING OFF THE
STREETS FOR GOOD. IN THIS CASE
SCENARIO COUNTIES WOULD HAVE AT
THEIR DISCRETION THE ABILITY TO
DETERMINE THEIR OUTSTATION
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS WHERE
THEY WOULD BE POSTED IN WHICH
STAFF WOULD MAKE UP THAT TEAM.
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE O THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. BUT ALSO
FOR THE DEDICATION FOR WHICH
YOU ARE TACKLING ARE STATES
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. SO ON
BEHALF OF THOUSANDS OF COUNTY
WORKERS REPRESENT REPRESENTED
BY SEIU THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
DON'T FORGET US. WE ARE READY
AND WILLING TO HELP SOLVE THIS
CRISIS. WE'RE WILLING AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO PARTNERING
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE AS SOLUTIONS ARE
CRAFTED IN IMPLEMENTED. THANK
YOU I APOLOGIZE I TO LEAVE
EARLY SO- STAFFERS TO HERE AND
TAKE A NOSE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
BUT I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
SPEAKERS. INDIVIDUALS FOR BEING
HERE AND TURN OVER TO DOCTOR
RAMBLE AT. THANK YOU AND- IF I
CAN I JUST ONE OF. ALSO
APPRECIATE PUBLIC SERVANTS
DOING GOOD WORK EACH AND EVERY
DAY AND BEING ON THE FRONT
LINES WHERE. IT CAN BE TOUGH TO
SUFFER THROUGH VICARIOUS TRAUMA
OF. BEING EXPOSED TO STORIES
THAT ARE TOO REAL AND TO HUMAN.
TO IGNORE.
¡NTION AS WE DISCUSSED- OLDER
HOMELESS NESS AS AN AREA- WE
WILL BE LOOKING TOWARDS UNDER
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
FIGURING OUT IF WE CAN LOOK AT
THE HOME SAFE PROPOSAL AND
WHETHER OR NOT LOWERING THE AGE
THRESHOLD WILL ALLOW US BETTER
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS THE
OLDER HOMELESS SPECIFICALLY AND
SO WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT- I HAD A GENERAL QUESTION
IF I COULD ABOUT THE PROPOSALS
FROM THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WANTED
TO BE SHARED. WOULD HAVE LIKED
MORE QUICK FROM THOSE WHO ARE
ON THE COMMITTEE BUT- I DO WANT
TO KNOW HOW YOU GOT TO THE
PERCENTAGES REGARDING CO C. AND
LARGE CITIES- AND- YOU KNOW I
WILL JUST. REPRESENT A LITTLE
MORE OF A RURAL AREA AS WELL AS
I DO RECOGNIZE FRESNO WAS ONE
OF THOSE THIRTEEN LARGEST
CITIES. BUT SAN JOAQUIN AND
TRANQUILITY AND FOWLER AREAS
THAT ALSO ARE STRUGGLING WITH
HOMELESSNESS THAT. WILL NOT AND
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO.
REPRESENT ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I HAVE AND LET
ME START BY SAYING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND AS YOU CAN SEE
THERE'S DIFFERENT PROPOSALS
HERE UP BUT AS WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE TWO BILLION BASICALLY
WE TOOK IT IS WHAT WE TOOK A
LOOK AT THAT THE WAY TO KEEP.
THE STRUCTURE AND THE HAVE
DOLLARS A STRUCTURED AND
FOLLOWED. THROUGH THAT
TRADITION BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY WORKED
ON ON ON THAT AND SO I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS THE BEGINNING
OF A PROPOSAL BUT WE THOUGHT
THE BEST PLACE TO START IS
WHERE WE LEFT OFF OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND- IN IN I KNOW
I DON'T NEED REMINDED BUT FOR
THE SAKE OF THE CONVERSATION
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED OFF WAIT
WITH HE OLLARS. IT WAS ON THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE AND THE
CITIES AND THEN IT WAS EXTENDED
LAST YEAR TO SIX FIFTY WITH THE
CITIES COUNTIES AND CONTINUES
OF CARE- AND SO WE FOLLOW TO
WHAT IT WHAT IS NEW HERE I
DON'T REMEMBER FROM THE PAST
WAS THE FIVE PERCENT. OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE IN
CITY. HE'S A PORTION OF IT BUT
THE CAN. OF CARE IS A FAR AS I
AS FAR AS I. HAVE BEEN ABLE TO.
THE WORK ON THIS DOESN'T
NECESSARILY. DEFINE WHAT THAT
IS AT THIS POINT IN TIME. ON IN
SO IN. AN ATTIC THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY LEGAL IF YOU LIKE TO
ADD. JUST FOR- CLEAR THE I DO
THINK HE HAS GONE OUT AND
HAPPENS NOT CRAMMED SO WE'RE
STRUGGLING TO. THOSE ALIGNED
WITH OUR STATEMENTS OVERALL BUT
JUST WANTED TO CREATE THAT. YOU
KNOW THE FINAL QUESTION IF I
MAY IS REGARDING YOU BOTH IN
THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME AND HE'D
FUNDING I BELIEVE. THE FINAL
PERCENTAGE THAT WENT TO YOUTH
WAS ROUGHLY 10% IS THERE A
THOUGHT TO HAVE ENSURING THAT
THERE'S ALSO A FOCUS ON THE
YOUNGER SPECTRUM WITHIN THIS
PROPOSAL OR IS THAT SOMETHING.
TIME MISTER CHAIRMAN IN IN HALF
ACTUALLY THEIR REQUIREMENT IS A
MINIMUM OF 8% WITH RESPECT TO
COUNTY CEO SEES AND THE BIG
CITIES AND THEIR PROPOSAL THAT.
IS WITH THAT WE'VE ALL
PRESENTED TODAY WOULD REQUIRE A
MINIMUM OF 10% OF THIS FUNDING
BOTH THAT PORTION THAT WOULD GO
JOINTLY TO CITIES JEFF JOINTLY
TO COUNTIES AND CO SEES AND THE
PERSON TO GO TO THE BIG CITIES
10% OF EACH OF THOSE POTS WOULD
BE A MINIMUM- ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AMONG YOUTH. IN
MARCH- I YOU KNOW OF- I DON'T
SITE ON THAT THAT BESIDES AS WE
PLANNED INTRODUCED THE BILL SO
WE CAN PLEDGE OUT SOME OF THE
POLICY PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT HAD
TO ADD AS YOU MAY HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS. BUT THAT THIS
QUESTION THAT WE NEED TO ANSWER
THIS POLICY PIECES THAT WE NEED
TO ANSWER AND WHAT THE LARGEST
QUESTIONS THAT. IF I MADE A-
THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT TO IS
LIKE A HOMELESSNESS IS THE
CLASSES OF OUR LIFETIME YEAH I
KNOW I DON'T HAVE TO CONVINCE
BUT I'M NOT PAY. ALMOST AS IS
THE CRISIS OF OUR OF OUR
LIFETIME IT'S PRESENTED BEFORE
US AND YOU TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
STATE BUDGET WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE A HOMELESS- ALLOCATION FOR
I MEAN WE HAVE A- ALLOCATION
FOR TRANSPORTATION WE HAVE AN
ALLOCATION FOR EDUCATION WE
HAVE AN ALLOCATION FOR HEALTH
AND I CAN GO ON THE LINE- BUT
WE DON'T HAVE ONE THAT SAYS
HERE IT IS FOR HOMELESSNESS.
HENCE WE'VE GOT HOMELESS OF POP
CALIFORNIA- UNANSWERED
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- THIS
ALLOCATION. FOR THE BUDGET AND
BVIOUSLY TO THE POLICY
CONVERSATION- AS- YOU CAN SEE.
WILL NOW BE TAKING ACTION TODAY.
BUT TO APPRECIATE- WANNA OFFER
AT TIME TO. SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY FINAL COMMENTS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE. SEEING NONE- WE WILL
THANK THIS PANEL FOR PRESENTING
HERE TODAY AND MOVE ON TO A
PUBLIC COMMENT- AS WE STILL
HAVE A FULL ROOM I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE US TO BE AS SUCCINCT
AS POSSIBLE. WHICH.
THE PROJECT.
HELP THE. SOME OF THE TO THE.
THIS FEATURE GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN MY CAROL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW POVERTY THANKS TO
THIS HEARING TODAY I THREE
BRIEF COMMENTS- FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO. HARDLY ENDORSE THE
COMMENTS BY MISS CABRERA. I
THOUGHT THEY WERE- SOMETHING
THE COMMITTEE SHOULD REALLY
TAKE TO HEART I THINK THERE WAS
A LOT OF TRUTH IN THAT AND I
THINK. MUCH OF WHAT SHE SAID I
THINK SHOULD HELP GROUNDWORK
THAT YOU AND OTHERS ARE GOING
TO DO IN THIS BUILDING GOING
FORWARD. I'M SECONDLY I WANT TO
COMMEND THE GOVERNOR AND THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS. I THINK THE
PROPOSALS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BRING FORTH IN THIS ARE VERY
BOLD AND INNOVATIVE. I THINK IN
PARTICULAR. HE HIS CALL FOR
STAB MACHINE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS AT THE STATE LEVEL IS
LONG OVERDUE. AND I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE DEPARTMENT WOULD BE
ABLE TO MANAGE THOSE WHILE WE
SAW HOW EFFECTIVELY. THEY WERE
ABLE TO HANDLE THE ESPY CASH
OUT ROLL OUT THEY DID AN
AMAZING JOB. AND I HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY WOULD DO
THAT AGAIN- AND THEN THIRD I
JUST WANT TO REALLY CALL OUT I
THINK. SOMETHING THAT GOT MAYBE
A LITTLE BIT UNDER PLAYED TODAY
WHICH IS THAT- IS MA'AM. HE WE
REALLY DO NEED TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING WE REALLY NEED TO
PROVIDE MORE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
WE NEED PROVIDE SERVICES MAKE
SURE THE PEOPLE GETTING. THE
BENEFITS THAT ARE DUE TO I'M-
BUT I THINK WE ALSO REAL YOU TO
KEEP A FOCUS AND A SHARP EYE ON
THE ISSUES AROUND PREVENTION.
KEEPING PEOPLE PLAY. AGAINST
PEOPLE WHO ARE HAVE A HOUSE
THAT WE PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
RENTAL ASSISTANCE A LITTLE BIT
OF EXTRA INCOME A FEW WELL.
BECAUSE THE TRUE PROBLEMS
CABRERA MENTION IS THE GAP
BETWEEN INCOME. THE COST OF
HOUSE. IT'S REALLY UP ALREADY
YOU FOR GOV. AND. FORGET
PATIENT. THE MAN TOOL. LONG
COOL. TO BE A TO. VENT TIONS
BEFORE THE OCCUR. I THINK MR AN
SELL MADE THAT POINT. ELK AS
FAST AS WE ARE GETTING PEOPLE
OUT OF HOMELESSNESS WE ARE
SEEING MORE PEOPLE COME ON TO
THE STREETS. SO WE MUST DO A
BETTER JOB WITH THAT AND WITH
THAT I'LL FINISH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AT KAREN LAYING ON
BEHALF OF BOTH SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY AND THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO MARYLAND AND
RATE AT SAN FRANCISCO IS OF
HARDLY SUPPORTS THE PROPOSAL IN
FRONT OF YOU FROM LOS ANGELES
ESPECIALLY THE FUNDING AMOUNT
TO BILLION DOLLARS I AND THEY
BELIEVE THAT THE ALLOCATION
WOULD BE SUFFICIENT FOR THEIR
NEEDS SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
SUPPORT OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S IN THERE I'M SURE THEY'D
BE DELIGHTED TO SEE TWO BILLION
A MINUTE GOT A LEAD. AND THEY
DID HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE CONCEPT OF MANDATE OF BUT
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THAT MIGHT
BE GETTING SET ASIDE RECENT
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL ABOUT THEIR
ABILITY TO DO THAT THEY DO ALL
I AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR AT
THAT SOME CHANGES IN THE MH TO
SAY- MIGHT NEED TO HAPPEN THEY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COUNTIES FUNDING LEVEL DOESN'T
GO ON AS DELTA THAT BASE. MONEY
WE DON'T WANT TO THAT WE FROM
THE FLEXIBILITY WOULD BE GREAT
THEY ALSO. VERY STRONGLY WITH
THE GOVERNOR ON THE POTENTIAL
NEW TOOLS RELATED TO LEVELS OF-
AT. THE BILL TO USE CONSERVE.
LAW AND LET CASE. THEY HAVE
HIGHER HOMELESS. DAY DO A LOT I
KNOW THAT SAN FRANCISCO ANALLY
WERE MENTIONED SPECIFICALLY
TODAY BUT THERE ARE OTHER
COUNTIES DOING REALLY
INNOVATIVE THINGS AS WELL
INCLUDING SAN JOAQUIN. YUBA
COUNTY WAS THE FIRST COUNTY TO
USE. OF THE TINY HOMES THEY DID
IT WITHOUT FANFARE AND THEY DID
A COUPLE YEARS AGO- SO JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THOSE ON
THE WORK THAT'S BEING DONE
OTHER COUNTIES AS AS
HIGHLIGHTED TO. SAN JOAQUIN HAS
A FULL TIME STAFFER JUST
WORKING ON THAT SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM.
YOUR PHONE WORKS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND I JUST WANTED TO BRING-
SOME STORY TO. THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE'RE HAVING- TONIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO BE
SLEEPING ON THE STREETS. AND AS
A- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TODAY. MY
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD SELF. HAD
EXPERIENCES WITH HOMELESSNESS.
AND THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR YOUTH. OUR MEMBERS. WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS IMPORTANT.
THAT WE CLOSE THIS GAP. BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
HAVE AN EXPERIENCE WITH
HOMELESSNESS. ARE FIVE TIMES
MORE LIKELY. TO EXPERIENCE AND
BE A PART OF THE CHRONIC
HOMELESS SITUATION WE HAVE
TODAY. AND SO WHEN IT COMES TO
SERVING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
THROUGH THIS PART OF FUNDING.
20% IS WHAT WE NEED TO START TO
REALLY TACKLE THIS ISSUE. I
STAND TODAY BECAUSE THERE ARE
THINGS THAT THE SYSTEM CAN DO
TO REALLY MAKE OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
THRIVE SO THAT THIS FUNNEL INTO
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS STOPS WE
AS THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YOUTH HAS WORKED ON A. B. ZERO
SEVEN- WHICH IS THE HOMELESS-
YOUTH PROGRAM- GRANT PROGRAM.
WHERE WE HAVE SOME INFORMATION
THERE TO INFORM HOW WE ARE
PLANNING TO TACKLE THIS LARGER
ISSUE AND THEN IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE FIGURE OUT A WAY TO REALLY
CAPTURE OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WITH
MD COORDINATE ENTRY SYSTEMS
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE TO COUNT
AND ACCOUNT. FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SO I
SOMEONE WHO HAS EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS AS SOMEONE WHO
JUST GOT A CALL FROM MY DAD WHO
IS NOW IN TEXAS BECAUSE HE WAS
THE PLAN THIS CAR IN LOS
ANGELES AND MOVED TO NEVADA
CAME BACK STILL SAVES BUT SINCE
IN THIS CAR AND NOW TO. NOT
ONLY HAVE MY FOR BEEN IMPACTED.
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS. WE'RE
IMPACTED BY THE OLD
HOMELESSNESS SO WE GOT TO SOLVE
THIS AND YOUNG PEOPLE NEED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE AND BE A
PART OF THE SOLUTION AND THAT
MEANS THEY NEED A BIGGER%
INVESTMENT FROM. THE LACK OF
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT IS BEING YOU KNOW
GIVE IT TO THIS THIS ISSUE THAT
WE HAVE GOING ON TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON I AM I
JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA THE FOURTEENTH.
LARGEST AT COUNTIES IN THE
STATE AND CERTAINLY- THE HUB OF
THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS- IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- WE SENT A LETTER
TO BOTH COMMITTEES AT THAT HAS
A LOT OF THINGS IN IT BUT I
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF COMPONENTS- FIRST OF
ALL. I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT BOTH THE
HEAT AND THE HOT PROGRAM
INTENDED TO INCENTIVIZE
COLLABORATION AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. AND OUR EXPERIENCES THAT
THAT HAS IMPROVED DRAMATICALLY
AS A RESULT OF THOSE TWO
PROGRAMS SO I THINK THAT WORK
THAT- YOU ALL A AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS DID ON THOSE TWO
PROGRAMS. HAS AFFECTION WAITED
BETTER RELATIONSHIPS LOCALLY
AND INNOVATION THAT IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE WHICH BRINGS ME TO
MY SECOND POINT. WHICH IS THE
CHALLENGE WE HAVE AGAIN AS
OTHERS HAVE MENTIONED IT
VENTING PEOPLE FROM THE- HOME.
WE MAY BE DOING VERY INNOVATIVE
AND IMPORTANT THINGS IN
ADDRESSING PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
EGGS. CURRENTLY IN EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE KEEP PEOPLE FROM
FALLING INTO THAT CATEGORY AS
WELL. AND HAVE ENCOURAGED
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS THERE OF
COURSE WERE SUPPORTIVE- AS A
NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
MENTIONED WITH ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS WERE PREPARED TO
DO- THE WORK TO- COME UP WITH.
COMPREHENSIVE PLANS TO ADDRESS
BOTH SIDES OF THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS AND- APPRECIATE. YOUR
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT WITH US AS
WELL. THANK YOU MA'AM. HI GOOD
EVENING PERSONAL HE DOES HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
CITY MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI JUST
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
THAT MR AND SELL OUTLINED AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE. AND THE GOVERNOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. JOSH
DUGGAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
FIRST RELATIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION WE
JUST WANTED TO STATE THAT WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE AND APPRECIATIVE
OF THE- PROPOSED ADDITIONAL
STATE INVESTMENT. AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S INVESTMENTS OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IN THE
KEEP IN THE HALF PROGRAMS- WE
TRADITIONALLY. URGE MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE TYPES OF. FUNDS SOURCES-
BUT THAT BEING SAID I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE AS
YOU'VE HEARD FROM SEVERAL
PEOPLE TODAY THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOES FOCUS
ON. AREAS THAT I THINK WE ALL
AGREE ARE KEY AREAS TO MAKING A
MEANINGFUL PROGRESS YOU KNOW
INCLUDING. RENTAL SUBSIDIES
STABILIZATION OF BOARDING CARE
AND- IMPROVEMENTS AND- ADDING
ADDITIONAL. LOW INCOME-
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING- THAT BEING
SAID WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
THAT WE'RE HOPING TO WORK
THROUGH WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE- ADMINSTRATION RELATIVE
TO THE CONCEPT OF REGIONS. AND
REGIONAL ADMINISTRATORS- AS WAS
MENTIONED HOW. CATION STILL
WEEKS ONE. WE'RE ARE.
UNDERSTAND BUT TYPE PROBLEM. IS
TRY. TO SOLVE TO AND PARTNER IN
THAT SALUTE AS WE FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
NICOLE ON BEHALF OF SEND BUTTON
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT APPRECIATE THE
FLEXIBILITY WE WORK REALLY WELL
AS A COALITION AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL IN THE HEAP AND HELP
FUNDING. HAVE BEEN WELL PROGRAM
TO- WANT TO ECHO A COUPLE OF
THE CONCERNS FROM MY COLLEAGUE
AT C. SACK ABOUT REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS AND HOW THE
REGION'S WILL BE DEFINED AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU MA'AM.
KAREN FOR KERRY. I'M ACCESS
CALIFORNIA AND CAL VOICES-
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND WENT LIKE
TO APPLAUD YOU FOR BRINGING UP
YOUR SUPPORT- IT'S A IT'S I
THINK A VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
THIS PUZZLE LET'S NOT MENTION
ENOUGH. AND AS FOR THE BIG
ISSUE I WANT TO SAY THAT WE ARE
WE ARE OBVIOUSLY. IN FULL
SUPPORT OF ENDING HOMELESSNESS
I'VE MENTIONED BEFORE I THE
SISTERS CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CHALLENGES-
BUT AT TO APPLIED AGAIN- WHAT
MICHELLE CABRERA SAID SHE SHE
WAS RIGHT ON THE COUNTIES ARE
PROVIDING GREAT SERVICES NOW-
TO PEOPLE THAT DON'T
NECESSARILY FIT INTO THE TARGET
POPULATIONS AND WE JUST WANT TO
INSURE. THAT PEOPLE ARE
RECEIVING SERVICES NOW AREN'T
GONNA LOSE THEIR SERVICES WITH
ANY CHANGES THAT TAKE PLACE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
LIBBY SANTOS ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING I THINK THE MAIN THING
AND ILLUSTRATED. IS THAT THIS
IS NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
PROBLEM NOR IS IT COMMON FOR A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION WE
ARE. IN DESPERATE NEED OF
SUBSTANTIAL- BUDGET DOLLARS TO
BE ALLOCATED BUT WE HOPE THAT
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE NAVIGATES
THE US. YOU ARE VERY COGNIZANT
AND EVEN WARY OF PROPOSALS THAT
SEEKS TO RECREATE THE WHEEL OR
INSERT ADDITIONAL LAYERS OF
BUREAUCRACY RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON DIRECT SERVICES
WE'RE DOING A GREAT JOB- OUT IN
THE STREETS WE JUST NEED.
ADDITIONAL US SOCIAL WORKERS
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES WORKERS AND WE NEED
THEM OUT WHERE THE PEOPLE ARE-
WE ARE REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE COMMENTS MADE. FOR GUARDING
OLDER PEOPLE AND THE FACT THAT
A LOT OF HOMELESS ARE NOT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OR MENTAL
HEALTH SUFFERS BUT RATHER JUST
POOR AND IN NEED. OF THE
SUPPORT AND SERVICES THAT OUR
PUBLIC SOCIAL SAFETY MEMBERS
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON
MAR ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND WE THINK THE
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS AND ALL THE
ADVOCATES HERE IN THE ROOM FOR
EVERYONE'S ONGOING WORK ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. AND WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO SUPPORT THE
MAINTENANCE OF A CARVE OUT FOR
YOU SPECIFICALLY AND- TO URGE
THAT THE CAR ABOUT BE AT LEAST
20% OF ANY FUNDING AS OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE OF LAID OUT IN
MORE DETAIL TODAY- WERE ALSO
HERE IS A FORMER CO SPONSOR OF
AB THREE ZERO SEVEN FROM LAST
YEAR. AND ECHO THAT BILLS
RECOMMENDATION THAT SERVICE FOR
PROVIDERS BE EQUIPPED TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF LGBTQ YOUTH. AND
THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE KNOW THAT UP
240% OF YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IDENTIFIES LGBT Q.
AND WE SEE THAT FROM TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE- NUMBER
OF UNACCOMPANIED ON SHELTERED
YOUTH WHO ARE TRANSGENDER
INCREASED BY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY PERCENT- SO WE-
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THIS MORNING
THAT MANY LGBTQ YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
FLEEING FROM. FAMILY REJECTION
AND ABUSE- AND HIS KNOWLEDGE
AND THAT THIS AFFECTS ALL
COMMUNITIES- THIS WE
APPRECIATED THAT WE WOULD JUST
URGE T ANY LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE. THE
IMPACT OF THIS ON YOUTH IN
GENERAL AND LGBT Q. USE IN
PARTICULAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON LOOK FEEL OF
US REPRESENTING HOUSING
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS C. S. H.
WE ARE ENCOURAGED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S SACK COMMITMENT TO
THE ISSUE- AND THE SOME OF.
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
THAT THE FLEXIBLE. HOWEVER WE
HAVE SOME CONCERNS. NUMBER ONE
WE THINK IT SHOULD BE MORE WE
SHOULD WE THINK A NUMBER- TO
MATCH THE SCALE OF THE NEIGHBOR
BE ABOUT TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
ON GOING- SECONDLY WE- WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE- REGIONAL
ENTITIES- WE THINK THAT THE
LAST. TWO ALLOCATIONS OF
KEEPING HAVE HAVE HAD TO
ENCOURAGE. COLLABORATION AT A
LOCAL LEVEL WE THINK ADDING AN
ADDITIONAL REGIONAL S. T. COULD
UNDERMINE SO THAT COLLABORATION
AS WELL AS IN SOME CASES
COMPETE- THIRD WE THINK HAVE
THE- DSS. IT MAY NOT BE
EQUIPPED NECESSARILY TO
ADMINISTER HOUSING PRO DON'T DO
RENTAL ASSISTANCE THEY DON'T A
MASTER CAPITAL WE THINK THAT IT
CITIES HCV SHOULD BE INVOLVED
SOMEHOW. AND LASTLY BOARDING
CARE WHILE THERE IS- OVERLAP
WITH HOMELESSNESS WITHIN
BOARDING CARE- IN ORDER TO.
INCLUDE THE FUNDING THAT WOULD
NEED IN ORDER TO ADDRESS-
BOARDING CARE COULD POTENTIALLY
CONSUME UP TO TWO THIRDS OF THE
SEVEN FIFTY ALLOCATED- SO YEAH.
THANK YOU SIR. I AM STILL
FISHER FOR THESE BAY OF A
COUPLE SUPPORT OF HOUSING
COLLABORATIVE BASICALLY WE'RE
OF VOLUNTEER GROUP FAKE FOCUS
MAINLY ON TRYING TO FIND
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS BUT NEED
SUPPORT OF SERVICES IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE STAY THERE WHICH IS A
PRETTY COMMON PROBLEM REALLY
GLAD TO SEE ALL THE STUFF THAT
TAP HERE I THINK. I THINK WE'RE
WE WILL GET INTO THE STRUCTURE
OF THE PROPOSAL BUT I THINK ONE
THING WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IN
TERMS OF THE SS. STRUCTURE PER
PER. BASICALLY IS THAT. RIGHT
NOW WE'RE LOSING BOARD CARE
HOMES AT A TERRIFIC RATE. AND
YOU KNOW TO COUNTIES ARE DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT I KNOW ONE
ALAMEDA COUNTY- WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO FIND MONEY FROM THE- POP
SIXTY THREE FUNDS IN ORDER
INCREASES TYPE IN ALREADY FOR
BOARDING CARE HOMES TO KEEP
THEM FROM GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS. I THINK THE SAN
FRANCISCO IS ALSO WORKING ON
THIS AND THEY'RE ALSO BUYING
FACILITIES AT THIS POINT THAT
ARE GOING OUT OF BUSINESS
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT WE'RE- IS
A REAL PREVENTION ISSUE HERE-
TO THE EXTENT WE LOSE THESE
FACILITIES THEY'RE GONE. YOU
KNOW WE GOT MORE PEOPLE ON THE
STREET AT THAT POINT. SO THAT
THE- BEEN I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF A- LOT OF POTENTIAL IN MAY
BE DEVELOPING ADDITIONAL
BOARDING CARE TYPE FACILITIES
MAYBE ONCE RUN BY NON PROFITS
INSTEAD OF PROVIDE PRIVATE FOR
WRITERS. BUT WE TO DO ANY OF
THAT STUFF WE GOT A REALLY WORK
NOW. ON THAT AND I THINK THAT
SOME OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS. SHOULD BE INVOLVED
RIGHT AWAY IN SAYING OKAY
HERE'S WHAT WE COULD DO BECAUSE
I KNOW IN OUR IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY. FOR EXAMPLE THE HOUSING
DIRECTOR OF WAS ABLE TO FIGURE
OUT WHICH HOMES I TO BE
STABILIZED FIRST. AND HAVE SOME
STANDARD FOR WHAT WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO OTHER THAN JUST
KEEP GOING. SO HE'S SOMEBODY I
THINK IT WOULD BE VERY VERY
HELPFUL THIS WHOLE PROCESS. TO
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR I MIGHT LOSE
PART TIME WITH CALIFORNIA BE
OKAY MY COMMENT SHORTS BEEN A
LONG DAY REALLY APPRECIATE THE
FOCUS FROM THE LEGISLATURE- ON
THIS ISSUE AND ON. A FOCUSING
ON THE INTERSECTIONS OF HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS WITH WITH
OTHER ISSUES. I LIKE HEALTH-
WE'RE GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR
FUNDING THIS YEAR- WE HAVEN'T
HAD TIME TO REVIEW THE
ALTERNATE PROPOSAL BUT ARE
ALSO. GENERALLY THE POSITION OF
ENCOURAGING THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO AS MUCH AS IT CAN. I IN IN
THAT VEIN- WE'D KNOW THAT OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALLOCATED
FINDS. OUT TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FOR LOTS OF THESE ACTIVITIES
DOES HAVE BEEN NEEDED FUNDS-
BELOW WHAT YOU KNOW I THINK.
ALL EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
WOLD. AGREE SUFFICIENT- BUT
HAVE NOT BEEN NECESSARILY
LEVERAGED WITH. A COMMENSURATE
POLICY CHANGES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THAT WOULD GET LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MOVING ON. BILL
MORE HOW. ON MAKING SURE THAT
HOUSING IF BALL. AB SO WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE AS A- OF THIS
YEAR. BODY THE- TO LOOK AT SOME
OF THE THINGS SOME OF THE CHIU.
THAT YOU DID PLAY HOW A FIGHT
IN THE PAST. ABOUT THE
UNDERSUPPLY HAPPENING IN
COASTAL AREA AND IN. ABOUT A-
AYE IT'S WE CAN'T. FIX SOME OF
THOSE PROBLEMS AT. THIS BUT-
THANKS. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE SUB SIX COMMITTEE-
LAST WEEK AND- PROVIDE SOME
PRELIMINARY AND PUT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THERE IS NO
OFFICIAL POSITION FROM. THE
CITY AT THIS WEBER CLEARLY
APPLIED THE FOCUS OF THE
GOVERNOR ADMINISTRATION ON THE
HOMELESS ISSUE. AND THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE- YOU'VE HEARD OF.
YOU KNOW ABOUT THE- THE SERVER
SANTIAGO PULLS A WOOD BAT OF LA
IN THE TWO BILLION- THAT
OVERSEAS IS ENCOURAGING I
THINK. CLEARLY WILL BE
ADVOCATING FOR ONGOING SOURCES
OF FUNDING- THEY'LL BE
HOPEFULLY SOON I GUESS I SHOULD
SAY THAT THE- THE MAILER CARTER
WAS NOW CHAIR OF BIG CITY
MAYORS. AND I THINK LIKEWISE OF
NOT FORMULATED A- A FORMAL
POSITION BUT THEY- WILL BE
MEETING SOON. WITH WITH SOME OF
YOU AND HOPEFULLY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF TO DISCUSS
THOSE. ISSUES A SORT OF WORK
THROUGH A BIT. GET VERY.
APPRECIATIVE TING. THUS FAR IN
FOUR TO WORKING WITH YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT. SEEING NONE I'LL JUST
TAKE A MOMENT OF I CAN THE
THANKS STAFF I DON'T THINK WE
DO IT ENOUGH- GENEVIEVE
MORELLO'S ANDREA MARGOLIS AND
NICOLE VASQUEZ THIS COULD NOT
BE DONE WITHOUT. THREE OF YOU
HERE AND JUST WANTED TO
APPRECIATE YOU FOR THAT SO WITH
THAT WE WILL CONCLUDE TODAY'S
TRYING HERE.